[Music]
this simple thing that we do every day
consume foods can have such a huge
impact that we don't even realize
[Music]
our choices impact the future
people realizing that their voice is
valuable and important
greetings everyone
prepare thyself for today's podcast
because this one wades into the waters
of veganism which is
a topic i care a great deal about
obviously nonetheless it's one that i
recognize can be an emotive subject for
many and a divisive maybe even
treacherous topic for others but fear
not today's waters are warm thanks to my
esteemed guest ed winters who is an
educator a public speaker
a content creator an author and vegan
advocate most known as earthling ed on
the internet and although ed is only 27
he's quickly become one of the most
compelling and powerful voices in the
vegan movement a millennial peter singer
if you will who
in addition to accumulating bazillions
of views here on youtube
has lectured at many uk universities
including cambridge he served as a guest
lecturer at harvard he's spoken at
several ivy league institutions and
major corporations like google facebook
and the economist
and has appeared in many mainstream
media outlets like the bbc
the occasion for today's conversation is
ed's tremendous new all things vegan
book entitled
this is vegan propaganda and other lies
the meat industry tells you which is
let's face it just an incredible title
vested only by the content they're in
so today we talk obviously all things
v-e-g-a-n including the moral philosophy
that underpins it
adds rebuttals to the many common
arguments against veganism the powerful
ways in which cultural forces drive
cognitive dissonance around our food and
consumer choices
the ethical and environmental
implications of those decisions
how to be an effective advocate very
important and many other topics so
if you find yourself vegan curious but
haven't yet found the will to commit i
suspect ed just might be the catalyst
you've been waiting for
we cover a lot today but there's so much
more to ed and his message so
if you find yourself eager to continue
your investigation i encourage you to
not only pick up ed's new book this is
vegan propaganda but to also spend time
on his youtube channel which is linked
in the description below because
it's all there people all of it is there
i think that's enough from me so please
hit that subscribe button and without
further ado i give you ed winters aka
earthling ed
it's so nice to meet you i've been
wanting to meet you for a very long time
it's it's somewhat surprising that we
haven't crossed paths in person yeah but
i've been following your work for for
quite some time and always knew that i
wanted to have you here and we're in the
perfect moment to have you here because
you have this amazing new book coming
out
this is vegan propaganda which is a
title for the ages like this is made for
the internet like it's so cheeky
and obviously
contemplates the fact that
the first thing that
uh a naysayer might say is that this
book is vegan propaganda yeah right
exactly yeah
that was the idea behind it um i mean we
always when we were kind of coming up
with the title for the book we went
through so many different iterations for
it and um we kind of landed on this idea
of propaganda because i made a video and
i used the word vegan propaganda as kind
of like a thing that people say about it
about the information and we're like
let's run with that you know there's
something in there so we like messed
around with it a little bit and we're
like this is vegan propaganda is a good
kind of tongue-in-cheek disarming of
that phrase that we kind of hear often
as vegans i think it's perfect
i love it
um in in thinking about you and your
advocacy and and the way you sort of
comport yourself in the world and and
carry this message that you care about
so deeply
i think that what is so
indelibly powerful about you
specifically is this
very intentional elegant style of of
communication that you have
um
that uh and this level of like
patience and unflappable equanimity like
equanimity really is like the touchdown
and how you kind of interact with people
when you talk about veganism
and address
the pantheon of arguments that get
hurled in your direction as a defender
of this way of life
and in that there are
so many different
uh aspects of
the vegan lifestyle there's health
there's in the environment
sustainability there's compassion all of
that but but your primary animating
forces is really rooted in ethics and
and moral responsibility so i think a
good place to start is just to
unpack
that a little bit and kind of how you
got into this to begin with
yeah i mean the way that i see veganism
is that it is a moral issue i often say
to people like even if eating animal
products was you know just as bad for
the environment the exact same for the
environment and had no negative
repercussions on your health and it was
exactly the same both ways even though
it isn't but even if it was that case
there's still a moral
reason to be vegan you know the animals
and so for me i've always come at it
from that moral angle and i think that
the
the other arguments really supplement
and solidify that reason to be vegan in
a way that kind of makes it undeniably
the right thing to do but that moral
framework has always been really
important to me and it was the decision
or that was the
the kind of thing that led me to the
decision to change myself and
i went vegan in 2015 and i'd been
vegetarian for about eight months before
then and the reason i went vegetarian is
because they came across this story
about a truck carrying around six and a
half thousand chickens crashing on the
way to a slaughterhouse near manchester
which is a city in northern england and
i was reading this story and just
feeling so dreadfully sorry for these
chickens the journalist was describing
how many of them had died you know there
were more who were alive but they were
on the side of the road they were
mutilated they had broken bones broken
wings and i realized that they could
suffer which is such a strange thing to
realize because obviously the animals
who we farm can suffer but how often do
we ever stop and think about that i i
never had and so i was thinking about
these chickens who were suffering and
then i realized well hang on a minute
it's not this the chickens on the side
of the road you know the destination
that we're heading to
is hardly much better potentially even
worse than for many of the chickens
because of what they endure in these
slaughter houses so i felt like a
hypocrite because in my fridge was a kfc
and i used to love fried chicken it was
like my favorite food i had a kfc outlet
that was about maybe a 5-10 minute walk
from where i used to live in london
and i went there so often that i became
very accustomed to the workers and they
knew who i was and you know we had this
kind of like rapport going and it was
just this kind of bi-weekly
twice weekly kind of pilgrimage that i
went on to get my fried chicken
but anyway my fridge was some leftover
fried chicken but now i'm empathizing
with chickens in a way i never have
before and i thought hang on a minute
you know what are my values when it
comes to animals and one thing i often
ask people is you know are you against
animal cruelty and we all say that we
are people who commit cruel acts to
animals are seen as some of the worst
people that can exist and we really look
down upon violence towards pets like
dogs and cats and and such but we turn a
blind eye to the cruelty that's
inflicted on farmed animals and indeed
animals that have exploited in other
ways as well
so when i ask people are you against
animal cruelty what i'm trying to do i
suppose is highlight that contradiction
our values you know when we say about
cruelty and i say to people can you
define what that means to be cruel to
someone you know people will always say
that it's about causing physical or
mental you know emotional harm it's
about doing something unnecessary that
negatively contributes to someone else's
well-being you know when we think about
what we do to animals of course it's
cruel you know we mutilate them we
exploit them we forcibly impregnate them
we take their babies away from them and
then we take their life from them
prematurely for an unnecessary reason i
mean to me that's like the definition of
being cruel to an animal so i realized
that in that moment thinking about the
kfc thinking about the chickens and
realizing that
there was this kind of disalignment in
the person i thought i was when it came
to animals and the person i actually was
and so i kind of reached this fork in
the road if you feel pardon the pun but
this fork in the road where i could
choose to kind of bury my head in the
sand and hopefully repress those
feelings and just get on with my life
and not worry about animals anymore or i
could accept this something not quite
right with my values and my actions and
i chose the latter and went vegetarian
because i didn't know anything about
dairy or eggs
and then i saw earthlings which is a
documentary
that exposes what happens in u.s farms
and slaughterhouses the movie we all
begrudgingly watch right exactly we have
to get dragged to watching it and then
we're never the same it is a hard watch
isn't it it's like an hour and 40
minutes of objective
i guess undercover hidden camera footage
that just shows what happens to animals
and after that i went and spent time
with rupert the hamster who was my first
real pet and i don't like to use the
word pet so much but more like companion
animal you know he was kind of my
companion and
i had rupert in my hands and i was
looking at rupert the hamster and i gave
him some broccoli because broccoli was
his favorite food he loved broccoli
absolutely loved it so i gave him some
broccoli and i was looking at rupa
eating this broccoli with his cute
little paws he always looked so adorable
and i was looking at him thinking
there's so much about rupert that
creates moral worth for him you know
he's an individual he has likes and
dislikes and he loved the broccoli but
he didn't like other things like kale
for example you know he had likes and
dislikes things that made him root but
the hamster
and i thought about all the animals who
were exploited in
all the different ways to exploit them
you know i wasn't eating meat but i was
still consuming dairy and eggs i was
still perpetuating systems that
exploited animals and other means and it
really dawned on me in that moment that
the issue of what we do to animals isn't
just really about food you know food is
a symptom of the problem the problem is
a mentality that creates the
justification for these systems to exist
in the first place the fact that we view
non-human animals or these non-human
animals with such little worth that we
can then justify doing everything that
we do to them that's the problem and
i realize that veganism isn't just about
eating plant-based food it's about
challenging that mindset that values
non-human animals as having such little
worth that we can do these unspeakably
cruel things to them and not bat an
eyelid about it most of the time
a lot of people have an analogous
experience where they're witness to some
you know
type of animal cruelty
and they're compelled to kind of reckon
with how that measures up against their
value system
but
not that many people use that as a lever
or tipping point to actually make change
i mean there's so much packed into that
there's the level of cognitive
dissonance this idea like you know we
all flinch and look away from things
like earthlings and slaughterhouse
videos and stuff like that for the very
reason and you talk about this like the
very reason that it will compel us to
confront that dissonance and if we do
that then perhaps we either need to make
that change that we don't want to make
or we have to live with that level of
disconnect which creates kind of like
you know just a lack of integration with
just being human right
so you had this moment like what was it
about
your background or you know leading up
to that that you were kind of primed to
make that change that so many struggle
to make
well i think that we often
when as vegans we often think of this
one moment you know i saw earthlings
that made me vegan but what we forget or
don't often realize is that for our
whole life there are all these little
moments that are building up to this
this kind of realization
and so throughout my whole life you know
i was raised with this mentality that
you know animals should be cared for you
know that people that do bad things to
animals are wrong that we should you
know try and protect our environment you
know i was raised with these values and
i was raised with the i guess the
concept that a world with reduced
suffering is preferable so this was kind
of like the mentality i had but i never
really connected all of these components
with you know being vegan or with the
consequence of not being vegan so for me
it was just like this i suppose domino
effect of thinking about these different
points in my life you know for example
i stopped going to zoos before i stopped
eating meats and dairy and eggs and the
reason i stopped going to zoos is
because i had seen the documentary
blackfish and the documentary blackfish
made me not want to see go to aquariums
but then i went to barcelona zoo and in
barcelona zoo i saw a bear and this bear
just looked so solemn and so sad they
were just sat
just sat down in this very small
enclosure looking around and i kind of
followed their eyes they looked around
the enclosure and looked at the four
walls they were trapped in and it dawned
on me that these animals are also being
kept in captivity like the orcas at sea
world are
so then i left i left barcelona zoo and
never went to another zoo after that so
i had these kind of moments that made me
realize that what we're doing to animals
isn't something that's good for animals
it's definitely not but also it's
something that contradicts kind of the
values that i have towards how we should
treat them and really just this last
piece of the puzzle was just been
kind of confronted if you like with the
objective reality of you know this is
what you're paying for when you go into
supermarket and you buy this you know we
may we may view these decisions as being
unconscious because they they are
unconscious but they have this very real
tangible consequence that we often don't
think about and so i was forced to go
when i go into a supermarket or i go
into a restaurant or wherever it is and
i give my money to these industries i am
personally funding these very things
that i'm feeling very upset about to
continue and how do i as a person who
wants to reduce suffering who thinks
that a world that you know
obviously we're never going to create a
utopia but a world that is trying to
reach that utopia as much as we can how
does paying for slaughterhouses to exist
how does that work in this kind of
vision of the future that i would like
to live in
it doesn't so it was all these little
moments but then this just this
overarching realization that i'm not
living in alignment then i'm
fundamentally a hypocrite when it comes
to my treatment of animals and that was
the final piece to go there is a problem
here that is
bigger than just this food problem it's
a mentality issue and as a consequence
of that i have to be that example of
what i want to see right
um
so where does the transition from
simply living this lifestyle turn into
this is my life's work yeah
that's a big leap right it is i
had been vegan for a little while um and
my partner she had been watching some
youtubers
and we've been watching a lot of them
you know absorbing a lot of information
about veganism i'd learned about the
environmental stuff i'd learned about
the health impacts both you know
individual chronic health but also kind
of a global infectious disease risk
problem as well antibiotic resistance
all these things i'd learnt about the
true scale of the problem and how
just this simple thing that we do every
day consume foods can have such a huge
impact that we don't even realize like
it's one of the most important decisions
that we make every day for ourselves but
also for the health of the planet and
every single being that coexists here
with us it can feel i suppose kind of
maybe a little bit
over exaggerated to make such a claim
but our choices impact the future you
know impacts us in every single way that
we can possibly think of in that sense
so when i started to realize the
enormity and scale of the problem i kind
of felt that i needed to do something
about it that simply just living this
way myself wasn't enough because i'm
still kind of allowing these actions to
continue and
before i was vegan i kind of didn't know
and i think about how i'd have reacted
if someone had given me this information
you know would i have changed earlier
you know would have had that realization
before
and i think about all the people in the
world who align with the same values
that i have and he would probably make
that change like i did if they kind of
realized the same things that i realized
and so being silent in the face of
adversity is still allowing that
adversity to continue it's still a form
of complicity because you're being a
bystander to that exploitation and
damage
continued to happen so i realized i
needed to
speak up in some way and that started
off by just being you know uploading
youtube videos and the first ones i did
was very rough and i was you know super
nervous and but i felt it was important
to try and communicate this message
because so many people just have never
heard about it before at least i've
heard about it but i've never really sat
and thought about the reasons to be
vegan so it was really youtube from the
get-go yeah for you pretty much you are
a true millennial yeah
right take that box though did you study
philosophy or argumentation or discourse
like you have such a facility with
language
and uh you know like i said earlier just
this composure about you that feels very
crafted and skilled like where did you
learn
how to do that i mean it was really
trial and error it's very kind of you to
say but there's there was no
real kind of education that i went under
i studied film and tv at university i
had this aspiration of being some big
movie director but
quickly realized that that's not what i
wanted to do but i could have those
transferable skills and apply it to to
being a youtuber of course but for me it
was just a process of trial and error i
kind of had these conversations with
people on the street just very rough
conversations at the beginning where i'd
go out to places like
you know leicester square or trafalgar
square in london and try and strike up
conversations with members of the public
and ask some hopefully property
questions
but i quickly realized what worked and
what didn't work and i quickly realized
that
having an aggressive tone or using
certain language or kind of putting
someone in a defensive mode
doesn't help people reach a positive
conclusion yeah and you know i had
conversations with people where i
overstepped the mark a little bit where
i maybe was a little bit too
or at least i came across a bit
judgmental i came across like i had this
air of superiority and i thought well
who am i doing this for because
being an advocate you are trying to
represent something and being an
advocate for this movement means i'm
trying to represent something or someone
who isn't me you know the animals whose
voices we ignore because their screams
are behind walls of slaughterhouses so
if i'm trying to be an advocate for them
then i can't allow this kind of
self-serving
um
philosophy of wanting to make myself
feel good by allowing these emotions to
overtake me you know this kind of anger
or this frustration you know that that's
self-serving but if i'm trying to be an
advocate for them someone else i need to
think about their best interests and i
quickly realized that you know allowing
these kind of self-serving emotions
wasn't productive and trying to be this
i suppose i'm a voice of someone's
conscience you know when i'm in these
conversations i'm trying to not impose
myself but really just allow someone
else to understand themselves better you
know themselves trying to allow them to
understand how they view these
situations you know what what attitudes
do they have and so you know i try and
revolve these conversations around
asking questions and trying to get
people to understand their own beliefs
rather than telling them what my beliefs
are yeah well you're very effective in
that and i i want to put a pin in that i
want to come back to effective advocacy
in in in the later stages of this
conversation
because i think that's super important
and interesting um but on the thread of
sort of advocating on behalf of a vegan
lifestyle
i feel like the overton window has
really expanded like even in the last
couple years like this is now
part of the mainstream discourse people
are not confused about what it means so
much uh people are interested and and
intrigued by it um so i want to kind of
establish the moral landscape here and
then expand upon that to for you to just
kind of
advocate on behalf of this in your own
words like why should somebody go vegan
i mean you do these you go around to
colleges and i want to talk about how
you
set up these these booze like lucy and
peanuts and say you know i'm
you know everybody should go vegan prove
me wrong and all of that so you've had
hundreds if not thousands of these
interactions
but if somebody came to you and just
said
ed tell me why i should be vegan like
how do you respond to that
i think it comes down to a number of
factors but the first thing to
acknowledge is that we can be vegan what
sets apart our current time from times
in the past is the fact that we have
that option in the way that previous
generations didn't throughout history so
the first thing to acknowledge is that
it's a choice and once we recognize it's
a choice it then becomes a moral issue
obviously what we do to animals is a
moral issue because we all think that
animals deserve some form of moral
consideration you know that's why we say
animal cruelty is wrong and we even talk
about animal welfare because we have an
understanding that we want to reduce
suffering so we recognize that what we
do to animals is a moral issue and then
we recognize that what we do to animals
is a choice and isn't something that we
have to do so then we have to look at
why we think animals deserve moral
consideration and i always think about
it from from my own perspective as a
human first
and i recognize that as a human
because i have things like sentience
individuality
the capacity to feel whether that's
pleasure or pain happiness or suffering
that i have you know an awareness of my
surroundings basically that i have this
sentience that assigns me moral worth
because when someone harms me it's
causing me suffering when someone does
something to impede on my life that's
impeding on my life right and that's
kind of broadly why we recognize that
arbitrarily harming not be humans based
on superfluous reasons such as sexuality
or ethnicity or whatever it may be sadly
enough we recognize that's obviously
wrong because these people sentient
individuals have these capacities in
much the same way that we all do of
course so if i understanding moral work
to myself based on these characteristics
and traits i have to work out whether or
not the non-human animals also tick
these boxes you know are pigs chickens
cows marine animals are they sentient
you know are they conscious do they have
the capacity to suffer feel pain also
pleasure happiness perhaps as well and
we know that they do you know we
recognize that with the animals we have
in our homes that dogs and cats have
these personalities things that make
them fluffy the cat or you know boxer
the dog whatever name we might assign to
these animals we recognize this about
them and we know that they have this
broad spectrum of emotions
and we know that with the animals who we
farm and who we exploit as well and so
when i think about them as individuals
i have to think about what moral
justification do i have to arbitrarily
harm them and unnecessarily kill them
and you can't morally justify that in a
current context of the current context
of a modern day society so it's about
recognizing that these animals from a
moral perspective should have work that
transcends the the reasons we use to
exploit them you know taste food
nutrition
you know we can get nutrition from
plant-based sources instead so when we
recognize it's unnecessary and we
recognize that these animals have these
capacities
that becomes what i would describe as a
it becomes a moral obligation to be
vegan because it's the best way to
reduce suffering to its fullest extent
when it comes to our treatment of
animals
we're all against animal suffering all
against animal cruelty so it's about
working out how we apply that logic the
most consistently and farming them in
any way or taking them to a
slaughterhouse to kill them which is
what happens to every farmed animal even
if they're raised for dairy and eggs you
know they still meet the same
miserable end prematurely
that can't be changed while we still
farm them and that causes suffering
cruelty so the best way to extend that
to its first extent is by no longer
paying for these things to happen in the
first place
there's so much cognitive dissonance
that comes into play and there's this
leap to really embracing the
individuation of these animals and i
feel like society is
structured to
entrench that cognitive dissonance and
prevent us from
empathizing with the individualistic
nature of these animals we all know with
our pets yes we can see that and we
understand that but then this wall comes
down when it comes to other species
particularly you know
farmed animals for our food
where
we're not so quick to make that leap
right like how do you the psychological
aspect of it to me is almost more
interesting than the intellectual
arguments it's like you can make those
intellectual arguments and we all get it
but there's a gap between that
understanding and behavior change that
lies in this very murky terrain around
how the human animal operates
it's so important and why you said that
i think is is really profound because
the
it's really easy i suppose in principle
to get people to understand the reasons
why change is important but as you say
there are these barriers social
psychological emotional that can
restrict us from making those rational
choices i mean the third section of the
book is really trying to address that
and i think we have to understand the
mechanisms behind why we have this
attitude and you know broadly speaking
we categorize animals into three kind of
groups we have you know wild animals we
have pets and then we have farmed
animals and by categorizing animals in
that way it allows us to treat them
differently based on the categorization
we've given them so
in a sense what we do is we otherwise
farm animals and we've otherized humans
throughout history to find you know to
them provide a justification for for
causing unnecessary harm and that's what
we do with farmed animals we've
otherized them and so we kind of view
them as being abstractions you know we
have pets in our home and we assign them
individual personalities but pigs and
chickens well they're just this abstract
concept you know pigs are dirty chickens
are stupid so by kind of assigning just
this one characteristic all these broad
characteristics to an entire species it
makes what we do to them more palatable
because we're not viewing them as
individuals and i think part of the the
problem with the scale of animal
agriculture is it further allows us to
detach from that individuality of each
animal even when i'm advocating i i'm
quite conscious to make the point of
whilst it's terrible that we farm 80
billion land animals and we kill
somewhere between 0.8 and 2.3 trillion
marine animals every single year whilst
that is obviously terrible because of
the numbers what's important is that
those numbers are made up of individuals
you know solitary individual animals who
are experiencing everything themselves
so i think because we've otherized
animals we've created these abstract
concepts of what these species that we
farm represent it then allows us to not
have to really engage with the actions
that we're committing yeah it's it's
similar to our difficulty in
empathizing with a genocide versus the
one kid who's you know stuck in the well
exactly that's exactly right isn't it so
i think that part of this problem is the
detachment from the process you know
where we live in the cultures where we
currently are there is this huge
detachment from the slaughterhouse the
farm and the supermarkets and i think in
the u.s there was a study done in
schools that said that a lot of school
children think that chocolate milk comes
from brown cows right there's this huge
disconnection from you know what we're
paying for and what we're consuming and
so there is this element of having to
become more conscious as consumers you
know intellectually recognize the
reasons to make the change but then
challenge some of those barriers that
exist into that cognitive dissonance
the confirmation bias that we can all
you know grapple with at times we have
to be kind of mindful and conscious of
these external factors that influence
our behavior because by being mindful of
those external factors we can then try
and work out whether or not our actions
are aligning with our rational thought
processes and i think it's just as
simple sometimes as going to a
supermarket looking at the foods we
normally buy and just taking a moment to
pause you know just thinking about who
is this from you know who you know what
who did this used to belong to when i
buy meat this is a piece of flesh so
where did that come from and just trying
to take a moment to to be more
thoughtful in our decision-making can
help us sometimes see through those
unconscious barriers that can drive our
behaviors yeah yeah it's so
fascinating i think you say in the book
you cite these statistics people are
pulled about
their relationship with factory farming
most people say it should be abolished
or we shouldn't have it but 99 of those
people you know the next day go to the
supermarket and just pick up whatever
right
so it's so weird that we're that way or
that we understand that pigs are
as smart as dogs if not smarter probably
smarter right
um that they have personalities etc
and yet
bacon right like people just can't get
around it we're going to get into all
the various arguments that you feel
but on the subject of continuing down
this path of just you know making the
case for veganism
[Music]
it becomes harder and harder
to defend our habits the more educated
we are and that's really kind of the tip
of your spear like
prioritizing education
but being in a place of allowing people
to make their own decisions around it
absolutely um
we as a species are of course ignorant
about so many things and ignorance isn't
a bad thing because we can't ever know
everything but at the same time the
antidote to ignorance is education so
there can be i suppose this
belief that non-vegans have that vegans
can be uh you know judgmental have an
air superiority and i'm sure some vegans
do take those boxes
but by and large i think that
the role of a vegan advocate is really
just to try and give some you know to
provide some education to someone who
just has never heard of these arguments
i think what we have to understand is
that you know good people do bad things
we're all you know
guilty of we all live in some level of
moral ambiguity absolutely we can never
be morally puritanical can we and so i
think we have to recognize that good
people can do bad things and that these
bad things are driven by often external
factors such as
advertising such as you know a
detachment from the reality of what
we're purchasing such as
uh this proliferation of information and
you know industry-funded studies that
creates doubts in the eyes of the
consumer there are so many things that
lead us to making the decisions that we
make
and i think just having that recognition
that we are all capable of doing bad
things but at the same time we're all
capable of doing better and education
can be an antidote to that
you know to that ignorance aristotle i
said in the book says that you know the
roots of education are bitter but the
fruit is sweet you know obviously what
we do to animals is a deeply
uncomfortable topic and i suppose the
broader consequence of the environmental
damage the the personal health
consequences these things are terrifying
and frightening and it's often very
uncomfortable to learn something that
contradicts the way that we've lived our
entire life but the the consequence of
that the fruit of that
is something so important which is that
we're creating a better food system
which as a consequence of that improves
so many of these issues that we're
currently facing as a species mm-hmm
are you able to maintain hopefulness
amidst all of this
do you find yourself descending into
cynicism
it
it can really vary um some days i can
feel cynical some days i feel probably
overly optimistic but i think by and
large i have a huge amount of faith
whether that's misguided i'm not sure
but you know i think humans are an
incredible species because we are
obviously so
intellectual we're obviously capable of
doing so much and whilst we are deeply
flawed in so many ways we're also
capable of achieving something better
and i think one of the reasons why i
enjoy having these conversations and
going to college campuses and such is
because it allows me to connect with
people i would never normally connect
with cowboys you know farmers you know
people have very different views to me
but it allows me to sit down and talk
with them for you know 30 minutes 40
minutes and really get to know them and
understand how they feel and i often
leave these conversations feeling very
optimistic because i recognize that you
know deep down we all want the same
thing which is you know a better world
fundamentally you might have differing
views on how we get there but we all
have this idea that we want when it
comes to agriculture at least that we
want a more sustainable system a more
ethical system a more just system you
know a system that reduces disparity for
you know people in low economic you know
scenarios we all want to strive for that
it's just we haven't quite reached the
commonality of how to get there but
these conversations i have with people
they reassure me that when we sit down
and talk about these these issues and
these are big moral concerns these are
big philosophical topics just a
conversation can really help us reach an
air of commonality which leaves me
feeling a lot more empowered than i
probably without without that aspect of
my advocacy so you've lectured and
taught at many colleges you've traveled
all over the place you were a guest
lecturer at harvard which is super
interesting i think you're doing an
online thing with harvard yes like next
week right which is cool
but in addition to that like i mentioned
earlier you set up these booths on
college campuses and you entertain these
conversations with people about veganism
you share those clips on instagram and
on and on youtube so you've had so many
of these conversations and every
argument conceivable i'm sure has been
foisted upon you that you've had to
field
um
how many of those
conversations end up because you're only
choosing you know which ones to share
right you're having many more of them
like are you do you get the sense that
you're moving the needle or at least
leaving people with something to think
about i mean that's my sense
occasionally you'll have a frustrating
one but overall
my feeling is that young people are
engaging you in good faith and they may
have their head in a different place but
there's a lot of kind of mutual respect
that goes both ways in these
conversations and and irrespective of
the outcome like that's that gives me
hope like i think that's cool to just
witness
yeah i mean exactly right we
tend to upload nearly all the
conversations that that take place and
i've just been traveling for the past
few weeks i've got so much content
because think about the us people are
very open to telling you their views
um and that
that's a loaded statement in and of
itself it's a polite way of saying
there's a little bit of
you know division that occurs here
sometimes but people are very open to
that and that's part of the reason why i
like being here and so i've had you know
most of these conversations but you are
right by and large which is that
there is this i think respectful
dialogue that hopefully takes place and
i try very hard to facilitate that so
when people sit down you know the the
camera operator will start moving the
cameras you know checking the memory
cards checking the batteries and we do
that deliberately so that i have two or
three minutes just to sit and talk to
someone not about veganism you know what
do you study where are you from do you
like it just really build up a bit of
rapport because if we're going to engage
in these conversations where you know
i'm going to be challenging people
fundamentally on on their lifestyle and
their belief system we need to make sure
that we get into that with this positive
mindset so trying to just make someone
feel comfortable immediately is very
important because
if we want people to be vulnerable we
have to express vulnerability in
ourselves we have to be
you know able to i suppose make
um you know make statements that almost
con i guess what i'm trying to say is
it's important for us to be able to own
up to things that they're right about as
well and i think in a debate what can
often happen is people have this
reluctance to accept that they're wrong
or accept that the other person's made a
good point it's always you know i have
to be 100 right right nothing they say
can be valid and i think just taking
that moment at the beginning to build up
the report lowers both of our defenses
to be open enough to be able to say
that's a really good point that you've
made or i understand where you're why
you're saying that or yeah i've never
thought about that before because we
have this kind of almost very early
friendship emerging from just this
moment of rapport building
and i think having those kind of
techniques of just you know taking
taking the time to listen to someone
asking them thoughtful questions um you
know trying to understand their argument
there is this
i think fracturing that's occurring
within society where
we're kind of caricaturing people and
their beliefs based on you know certain
principles of you know their identity
and we don't actually take the time to
understand people's beliefs anymore and
i think
why i like having these conversations is
i'm interested to understand why people
think the way they do you know how did
they reach that conclusion why do you
think this is the way that it is because
it makes me better as an advocate as
well you know how am i supposed to be
i suppose competent at debating people
if i don't understand what their point
of view is right so
i think that builds respect as well just
listening and being being genuinely
interested and sincere in your um
i guess your care of their beliefs yeah
and to that point i assume it's
intentional on your part to purposefully
attend
colleges with animal husbandry and
animal agriculture departments like
cornell and texas a m like those are you
know like there's a lot of students that
i'm sure you interacted with who are
actually studying how to be animal
agriculturalists
on some level
and that's and that i'm sure you're
confronting a lot of cognitive
dissonance i mean they're being
indoctrinated is the wrong word but
they're being kind of trained and
educated in a particular way of life and
and profession that is at odds with your
you know core moral philosophy yeah that
exact scenario played out at texas a m
recently this guy sat down this uh
really proud tech center from rural
texas told me he didn't like the cities
he just liked being out in the middle of
the wild west
and he was studying animal ag
and animal like science and so he sat
down very respectfully and was just like
i'm really interested to hear your point
of view and i was like well that's great
i'm interested to hear yours and so we
started this conversation and he said
well i was told today
in my my class that dairy cows uh
like to be farmed they queue up to be
milked and so it's a consensual thing
and i said well that's that's a very
interesting statement but it kind of
misses the finer details which is that
you know we've selectively bred dairy
cows to produce excessive amounts of
milk you know dairy cows need to be
milked because they're producing milk
and it's uncomfortable for them not to
be milked so there's a reason why dairy
cows will walk themselves into the
milking parlor is because they have to
be milked you know otherwise it causes
the pain mystitis all of these things
but it doesn't make them you know
willing participants in their
exploitation just because they go for
this you know predetermined biological
process where they have to have their
milk released should be done by their
child of course but in the absence of
their child must be done through the
machinery just because they willfully
walk into that environment doesn't make
everything else we do to them consensual
so there is that that indoctrination
that exists within these courses because
farmers
by and large are raised in farming
communities and this is a really
important thing to recognize
and they're raised with a belief system
that's given to them by their parents
and their grandparents you know these
family these are family farms passed
down generation to generation and as a
child growing up in that environment
seeing what the farm means to your
family and feeling the expectation that
you have to go into that farming
scenario yourself plus you're in a
community that's just farmers and
farming families so your friends are
farmers you know you grew up with
farming children it's all you've ever
known so what choice do you have but to
pursue that i think it requires an
exceptional amount of humility um and
dedication for a child to break out of
that so then they go to universities at
you know colleges that are studying you
know teaching animal ag science so they
come from farming communities with
farming families go learn about farming
and then become farmers and it's all
they've ever known i think it's easy to
understand why
many farmers may not sit down like that
texan did and have a conversation with
me you know why they may feel threatened
by the presence of someone who's
outspoken about their veganism because
it's not just challenging their
livelihood it's challenging their entire
existence sure identity yeah completely
yeah right like i can easily
empathize with the level of
defensiveness or resistance that you
know somebody in that position would
have towards you absolutely
with your long hair and your you know
it's like come on dude the opposite of a
texan cowboy what do you know about my
life yeah exactly so how does that go
like how did it play out with that guy
really well i mean i was lucky in the
sense that he was very receptive and
open-minded
and he didn't leave with this revelation
that he was going to stop studying
animal science and become vegan that
didn't happen
but at the same time he left i would
hope with a
an understanding about veganism but also
an understanding about vegans that he
didn't have before i think that vegans
often have an optics problem sure that
we have this this perception of us which
is really damaging and and a lot of the
time we don't necessarily help ourselves
with that and i can be the first to yeah
i mean it's it's it's
incredibly emotive and divisive as you
have said um regardless of whether
you're pro or con just saying the word
you know
people get you know people get agitated
no matter what right
so first of all what does it even mean
why does that
word
you know tend to provoke people one way
or the other
and you're correct like vegans can be
their own worst enemies and there's a
lot of infighting and confusion amidst
the community that is not helpful no so
i think optics are a massive part of
that problem and
i think very quickly i realized that
being a messenger isn't
necessarily so much about what you say
about how you say it you know how you
come across and with that cowboy and
hopefully with most people that sit down
and talk to you are engaged with me in
one way or another i i just want them to
leave with the feeling that okay vegans
can be this way you know vegans can
listen vegans can be respectful vegans
can engage in a thoughtful manner you
know they're not going to call me an
animal murderer as soon as i sit down
and i think that that's an important
aspect of what i try and do is just
trying to i suppose reframe people's
perceptions of what being vegan means
because it's easy for us to distance
ourselves from doing something if we
don't like the person who's doing it so
if you know if we can't disagree with
the message that causing unnecessary
suffering to animals is wrong the next
best thing is to disagree the person's
saying it and so people are looking for
any excuse to you know i suppose
disembark from these conversations to
not have to engage and if we as vegans
perpetuating a stereotype that
people don't want to engage with then
then that's how they distance themselves
from from these really important issues
the first thing we have to do is be i
suppose personable and approachable so
that people will then want to listen and
if we fail that first hurdle and we
don't come across as the game's over
listen it's over just like yeah and not
only that you have to overcome all of
these other barriers and hurdles because
the media is hard at work at
characterizing you talk there's a whole
thing in the book about this and you've
made videos about this the mischaracter
characterization on behalf of the media
to you know paint a broad picture of
vegans and veganism as you know insane
militants and you know violent people
who want to kill babies etc all that
kind of stuff so people come in with
their preconceived idea that you have to
rebut
so you almost have to be all the all the
all the much more sort of patient and
yeah
conciliatory
it's it's it's hard at times um but
you're right there is
often
um
a concert maybe a concerted left is a
little bit too dramatic but there is
often an abundance of
media articles and press releases that
are staunchly against veganism you know
whether that's you know veganism makes
you ill young girls are going vegan
because they're trying to mask their
anorexia or orthorexia um that you know
vegans kill more animals that we're
destroying the amazon rainforest there
are these narratives that are
consistently perpetuated even though
they're consistently debunked and there
is this i think issue with people's
perceptions about veganism not coming
from any i suppose detailed research on
their part but merely just because
they've seen sensationalist headlines
about
it's passive media consumption that is
buttressed by
uh you know the advertising industry and
dairy check-off programs etc that you
know are feeding us
um this narrative about how to eat meat
is to be masculine and if you're going
to be vegan you're a soy boy and that's
for sissies and all of that
so there's that kind of
peace as well which for young men can be
very powerful as a lever in thinking
about these issues it is so important
and i think the
me and masculinity link is a really
important one for us to consider you
know it's easy to just
i suppose it's easy for us to to look at
men who consume meat for that reason and
view them as being these you know really
terrible people who were just all about
their ego and fragile and all of this
but it kind of does a disservice to the
incredible amount of pressure that comes
from advertising that comes from public
perception and peer pressure
um you know there are studies that show
that you know men can feel very
disenfranchised in social environments
where they feel that their masculinity
has been questioned by their friends and
that you know they're less likely to
choose plant-based options in these
social situations even if they you know
rationally understand the reasons to do
so that peer pressure and that societal
pressure of these expectations about
what being a man means and how that
equates to diets really puts a lot of
burden on on young men especially to to
fulfill that and of course you know
there are lots of issues with
you know this kind of
hyper masculine attitude that's
perpetuated especially now i feel maybe
more than has been in the past but i
think overlooks the fact that there is
this concerted effort probably from many
areas from industry and also from from
the media to perpetuate that narrative
you know you turn on the tv and
these fast food chains using
images of sexualized women or images of
men talking about you know eating meat
like a man
that's a
you know a message that's perpetuated a
lot and it weighs heavy on on the
psychology of young people growing up
and sure who they want to be and how
they feel they should conform
well let's go through some of the the
main arguments against being vegan since
you have field fielded on all of them
at the top of that list really is this
argument around personal choice like get
out of my business why are vegans always
trying to make me go vegan live and let
live yeah
let's say you earthling ed well say me
i
sometimes i think vegans can try and
make the point that it's not a personal
choice if it affects someone else i hear
that a lot you know it's not a personal
choice because there's a victim but you
know fundamentally it is a choice when
we go into a supermarket or a restaurant
what we choose to to buy is up to us to
to decide no one else can make that
decision for us so the first thing to
recognize it is it is a choice but then
by the recognition that it's a choice it
means that we don't have to do that
and when we talk about moral issues well
everything is a choice now i could leave
today
find someone and mug them you know rob
them i could find a dog and kick them
and stump them to death you know i can
choose to do all of these things but
they're not morally justified as a
consequence of being a choice so whilst
what we do to animals and what we choose
to buy when it comes to animal products
is undeniably up to us to choose it
doesn't mean that it's justified as a
consequence of that because every action
moral or immoral is is a choice
and i suppose i always say what about
the choice of the animals when we say
about personal choice
after people make the argument that
they're trying to you know protect
people's sovereignty and people's
ability to make individual decisions but
what it overlooks is the fact that our
personal choice is impacting the
you know the desire of of trillions from
others around the world and so what
about their choice if you know if they
had that choice they wouldn't walk into
a slaughterhouse we're so detached from
that equation though oh it's very
difficult for us to do that math because
of
the distance and the barriers that are
put up to prevent us from really
understanding that plus the fact that it
feels like my personal choice has so
little impact on this broader problem at
large
me ordering a cheeseburger or picking up
some ground beef at the supermarket
isn't going to really impact the state
of factory farming
but at the same time every mass movement
for our history has been formed of
individuals and so whilst as an
individual making personal decisions we
may feel like the impact that we have is
is small and as an individual choice it
is
but an individual choice
combined with millions of other
individual choices starts to have a huge
impact and so it's about being empowered
to recognize what we can achieve we look
across the world and we look at so many
problems
and you know as individuals there's very
little we can do about that you know we
can donate to charities but can we stop
war not as an individual necessarily we
can go protests and marches sometimes
that doesn't make a difference either of
course but when it comes to the
agricultural system and the way the food
that we consume is produced and the
consequences of that
is entirely something that we as
individuals and consumers have the power
to change you know there are subsidy
systems and there are legislative
problems from
you know governments and politicians but
fundamentally if we as consumers come
together and vote our wallets for a
different world we can create a massive
amount of change and so it's one of
those
rare issues potentially where we as
individuals have the power to completely
change their system so i think it's
about being empowered to recognize
the responsibility but also the ability
that we have to bring about change right
and recognizing that capitalism
fundamentally responds to shifts in
demand right so if the demand shifts and
people are
desirous of plant-based milk options
that's what you're going to see in the
supermarket and of course that is what
we're seeing we're seeing the
proliferation of plant-based options at
not only restaurants across the world
but the fast food outlets like they are
responsive to consumer demand and to the
extent that we can
um consolidate and marshal the messaging
around that demand and
get more people enthusiastic about this
these companies they're not you know
it's not mustache twirling people
sitting around a boardroom conspiring to
make people unhealthy and kill as many
animals as possible they're trying to
meet their quarterly earnings and if
they figure out a way to do that
by dint of exploring the plant-based
world then that's exactly what they're
going to do so i think it really is
powerful and it's not dissimilar from
this discussion around individuation in
the same sense that we struggle to
individuate these animals
we have to also
be able to understand that the
individuals amongst us comprise
a greater whole that is indeed very
powerful and you know youtube and
podcasts and things like that i think
have played a huge part in
in at a minimum
shifting the consciousness of the
younger generation to really care about
these things definitely um what's unique
about this issue in a sense is
you know throughout history we've never
had the opportunity to hear the other
side of the story you know parents
grandparents they were raised in until
you know the past 10 years or so what we
knew about animal agriculture came from
animal agriculture you know we were told
the animals are treated well why would
we ever question that we go into a
supermarket and we see these promotional
posters telling us one thing
this is all we're fed you know so we're
here so what's unique about now is that
we have this opportunity to go well
actually is there something else to this
is you know is there more to this is
there an another side to this coin
and when we can do that you know look
into that see what happens
there is this now growing awareness
about the impact that animal
agriculture has on the environment on
our health these things are stemming
from a public awareness a shift in
public consciousness that is also
stemming from a proliferation of
information through podcasts and youtube
that hasn't existed before so it's
creating a unique situation for us to
engage with ideas that potentially you
know older generations didn't have the
luxury of engaging with right
i hear you ed but i procure all of my
meat from
uh regenerative farms uh it's all
locally raised hormone free the whole
thing so
i'm doing my part yeah
it's a common argument now isn't it
and those animals are important in
regenerating the soil yes which is a key
to solving the climate crisis and
regenerative is like the new sustainable
word is the new buzzword that these
industries are using a lot um i think
the first thing to recognize is this
idea that people are supporting these
systems comes from
a good feeling it comes from the sense
that we need to do something differently
but we're kind of still stuck in this
paradigm of wanting to continue
consuming animals so we're trying to
find rationalizations to continue that
and this idea of regenerative beef
farming or lamb farming comes along and
it ticks the boxes of allowing us to
continue eating animals but also means
we can regenerate the soils and it gets
rid of all the problems and it
alleviates all of that cognitive
dissonance it takes everything that we
want
but is it true
that's when it becomes a problem so the
idea of regenerative animal farming is
as you rightfully say it creates a
system which can put nutrients back in
the soil it reduces the use of kind of
artificial fertilizers and crop
reduction can reduce the strain on
places like you know the amazon
rainforest and such which is currently
being you know decimated for feed
production and cattle grazing and
all these terrible things
but
when we think about regenerative farming
what we have to recognize is that it
uses up an incredible amount of land so
if we think about the us for example so
the usda states that currently about 41
of the land mass of the us is used for
animal farming when it comes to plant
farming for just for human consumption
it's only four percent so in the us ten
times more land is used to produce
animal products than plant products for
for humans directly and when we look at
beef farming in particular well it's
about twenty percent of the entire land
mass of the 48 contiguous u.s states is
used to produce beef which makes about
three percent of our caloric needs so
this is with a system that uses feedlots
you know this is with an efficient
system when it comes to land use so
simply parts
even if we believed in regenerative
farming we cannot continue to consume as
much meat dairy and eggs as we currently
do it'll be a fraction of that anyway
because there isn't the land or the
resources to produce the animal products
or the quantity that we currently
consume using these systems so even if
it was a viable alternative we'd still
be dramatically reducing the amount that
we consume
but
when we look at regenerative farming
there's a couple of aspects to look at
first is biodiversity and second is
emissions those are like the two main
things that proponents of this system of
farming will talk about so we look at
biodiversity to begin with the idea is
that grazing animals increases
biodiversity because uh kind of mono
cropping and of course indoor factory
farming is terrible for biodiversity
which it is but at the same time is
grazing animals the best thing for
biodiversity or is there an alternative
and when we look at biodiversity it's
very simple to recognize that forests
woodlands long grass meadows
wildflower meadows
increase biodiversity more than grazing
pasture lens do so what we need to do is
work out how we can maximize
biodiversity gains
so when we look at animal agriculture
and we look at it globally it uses 76
percent
so it uses 83 percent of all
agricultural land so over four fifths of
agricultural land is used to graze
animals now if we switch to a
plant-based diet we could reduce the
amount of agricultural land that we need
by about 75 percent and that's feeding
everyone on a plant-based diet we can
still reduce that amount of land by 75
so that means that we have all of this
land now that we no longer need to
to use for agriculture that we can do
something else with and the primary
thing we can do with that land is is
rewild it and that just basically means
returning the land that we currently use
for agriculture back to some form of
natural state whether that's swamps
peatlands forests woodlands wildflower
meadows whatever it may be we can return
that land back to nature and as a
consequence increase the fauna and flora
of of the world increase the
biodiversity that exists so that's what
we need to do if we want to prioritize
biodiversity gains when it comes to
emissions
there is an idea that grazing animals
ruminant animals sequesters carbon into
the soil which it does and the reason it
does that is through photosynthesis so
when an animal grazes they're turning up
the roots they're consuming the grass
which is encouraging and stimulating the
regrowth of these plants which
sequesters carbon through photosynthesis
and stores carbon in the soil and
something about the way that they're
walking on the land and seeding it in
some respects has some sort of
beneficial impact yeah and then the
manure replaces some of the lost
nutrients in the soil
but there's a couple of ways looking at
it firstly from an emissions perspective
when we look at the meta analyses on on
these on these farming systems
they're still producing
net emissions so the grazing animals are
still producing emissions and even in
the most generous circumstances
we're looking at only a 20 to 60 percent
of emissions being offset in these
regenerative farming scenarios but i
think what's really important about this
is whilst soil is a carbon sink it's not
a limitless carbon sink so after a
period of time soils reach something
called soil carbon equilibrium which
means the amount of carbon that can be
stored in the soils is is maximized
so at that point even if grazing animals
offset all of the emissions that they
produce which it doesn't but even if it
did at some point the soil reaches full
saturation you saturate it and at that
point it's
it's it's net emissions right just 100
emissions yeah sequestration
it really puts to the test
the whole allen savory kind of
philosophy around this and there's a stu
it's a study or an article called like
grazed and confused that is a really
great read that explains all of this in
great detail well alan savory released
this ted talk which went super viral
where he made the claim i believe was
something like just 50 percent of uh you
know pasturelands could you know reverse
climate change or something if if they
were grazed in the manner that he
advocates for which is an
unsubstantiated claim and grazing
confuse is a great example because it
looked at 300 sources and it looked at
all you know these farming scenarios to
try and work out whether there was any
veracity to the claims being made and
and realized that well yes it can
sequester some carbon it's it's nowhere
it's nowhere near going to offset the
emissions and with the soul carbon
equilibrium you reach a point where
you're not offsetting anything so as a
long-term strategy even if it did work
there's no legs to it because at some
point you either have to take the
animals and found them on more land
which means creating more agricultural
land or you have to stop the animal
farming so when we talk about you know
sequestering carbon the question becomes
well is grazing animals the only way
that we can put carbon in the soils
because by having to offset the
emissions the animals produce we're
limiting the capacity for our soils to
sequester
why are we trying to offset these
emissions when we can just not have
these emissions to begin with if we
weren't grazing cattle and lambs and
such won't have to offset the emissions
they produce
so again when we look at sequester and
carbon the best thing that we can do is
create is create forests and woodlands
and long grass meadows and wildflower
meadows because that not only increases
biodiversity but it also sequesters
carbon and does so in a way without
having to offset any of the negative
emissions produced by the animals in the
first place right and just to be clear
regenerative farming is far better than
factory farming it is a step in a
positive direction
to some extent
but
it will never
be able to scale to meet current meat
demand it's not really a solution to any
of these problems and the argument that
it is a valid participant in reversing
climate change is really you know the
error in all of this it's dangerous um
the grazing confused study said that
only one gram of protein per person per
day on average globally comes from
solely grass-fed animals just one gram
we need obviously um a lot more than
that when we look at animal products i
think
is something like you know 20 22 grams
or something is maybe coming from from
animal products right now so if we want
to get the protein that we we get from
animals right now but only from systems
of solely grass-fed production
well it's just not going to be possible
you know the united nations says that 26
percent of earth's ice-free land is used
for grazing animals but that's currently
what it is so
it has its benefits when you compare it
to factory farming you know obviously
the systems that these regenerative
proponents are talking about are
substantially better in many ways to the
system that we currently have of mass
feed production and factory farming and
the huge manure legumes that are
obviously just terrible in so many ways
but the question is is it the best thing
that we can do and does it genuinely
solve the problems that we're trying to
address and when you view it against the
alternatives the you know a
plan-based food system that's more
sustainable but also rewired landscapes
those concepts and that system of
agriculture and land management is
substantially better in every single way
than a system of regenerative farming
and
often proponents of this way of thinking
the regenerative animal agricultural way
of thinking will try and point the
finger at the way the current
plant-based food system is set up and i
see a lot of people right you're you're
going to poo poo this but you're eating
your mono crop
you know
farmed you know factory farmed plant
foods yeah well firstly if we swap to a
plant-based diet we would reduce arable
land by 20 anyway so even to switching
to a plant-based diet would still be
preferable from an arable monocropping
perspective just straight off the bat
but i think what's disingenuous about
that is it's trying to say that there's
no better way of producing plants
i recognize the plant-based food system
is far from perfect it's significantly
better
but it doesn't mean that it's as good as
it could be so by trying to say that
regenerative animal farming isn't isn't
a viable solution isn't saying that we
shouldn't try and make what we currently
do better when it comes to plant farming
and we should be adopting you know
better forms of plant-based agriculture
yeah you know regenerative exactly
plant-based farms bingo you don't want
to just do that exactly and then we've
got things like vertical farms
which is an incredibly exciting prospect
maybe when it comes to lab grow meat if
you want to look at producing meat
sustainably you know lab grown meat will
be when it's scaled up and you know
financially efficient enough will be
more sustainable than of course farming
anyway so it's it's seen as kind of like
this almost compromise but effectively
it's still causing huge amounts of
damage to our environment and of course
resulting in premature death of animals
and there's an alternative that exists
and will continue to become more
sustainable into the future as we engage
with these more technological
advancements within plant-based
production as well right so that kind of
covers the environmental arguments
around regenerative agriculture but
another thing that comes into play when
people are opting for grass-fed beef is
this idea that these animals are are
living a much higher quality of life i
think there's a lot of confusion over
the definition of grass fed and how that
that definition is sort of weaponized in
a way that people consumers
who are trying to do better uh might not
be aware of
the idea behind grass-fed um
a lot of it is kind of a marketing term
because you know grass-fed animals can
still be fattened on feedlots at the end
of their life yeah like the last 15
percent of their life or something like
that where they go and then they're just
eating grain to get them as fat as
possible exactly and it's still
considered it can be labeled grass-fed
that's right and i think the percentages
maybe vary country to country i think in
australia it might be as much as 25
of their life the final quarter so
it doesn't mean that these animals are
raised solely in these pastures and even
on these pastures they can be
supplemented with different feeds anyway
but and also there's there are still
components of animal agriculture that
exist such as the mutilations the
branding these things still exist even
in grass-fed farming productions and
they're still killed in in
slaughterhouses as well so you know
people often
say to me you know i'm against factory
farming everyone even if they support it
says they're against it and likes to
have this aspiration of supporting these
these kind of grass-fed systems because
again it's seen as a compromise
but ultimately when we view this this
issue
um
at its kind of most bare barest form
it's again about this notion of reducing
exploitation and suffering yeah the
animal is still getting a bolt in the
head and it's throat cut no matter what
so it may be better quote unquote but is
it objectively the best thing that we
can do no so we shouldn't be comparing
this middle scenario to the extreme of
factory farming we should be comparing
it to the other side which is you know
not exploiting animals in the first
place when it comes to the environment
when it comes to health and when it
comes to the ethics the not exploiting
animals is better in all of those
different ways even compared to this
middle kind of compromise right that
opens the door to a conversation around
the sort of dark side of of green
washing or incremental change because
these small changes and the marketing
that kind of
wraps around them makes people feel
better about their choices and kind of
ameliorates any type of
activism because
people are sort of sedated into
believing that their actions are lining
up when their values when in fact
they're not yeah we all like to be told
good things about our bad habits
and you know green washing and this kind
of concept humane washing
uh are really important tools that
industries will use and companies will
use to make us feel good about our bad
habits and so you know a lot of us are
familiar with the concept of green
washing you know companies trying to
overstate the sustainability impacts of
their products but humane washington is
something similar you know we go into a
supermarket we see a box of free range
eggs that's an example of humane washing
it makes us think that we're buying a
product that is quote unquote humane
and the names of the farms and the
picture of the red tractor and the you
know beautiful looking fields and all of
that exactly or the five-step welfare
program or whatever it might be there
are so many examples of it because
fundamentally these industries and you
know the
the suppliers the supermarkets know that
we care about these issues you know they
understand that and they know that if we
had uh or we saw a label that said you
know this piece of pig that you're about
to buy was slaughtered in the gas
chamber using this method and they were
raised in this way and here's the
picture of the farm we would probably go
oh you know that tin of chickpeas seems
pretty good now you know so they have to
sell us an ideal and they have to sell
us what we want to buy and that's really
dangerous because what we want to buy is
a complete odds of what we're actually
buying so it's about being i suppose
again a bit conscious off of these
choices that we're making and the word
humane is a really interesting word
because we use it all the time to
describe what we do to animals you know
it's acceptable to kill an animal if
it's done in a humane way or you know
what happens in china is obviously
terrible but in the us or the uk our
slaughterhouses are humane because they
have these regulations
but the word humane if we open up a
thesaurus
and we find synonyms means compassionate
benevolent kind if you're a humane
person you're inherently i guess a good
person a kind person but then how do we
benevolently or compassionately exploit
or kill someone against their need and
sometimes people say you can't call an
animal as someone i've heard this a lot
recently you know another someone and i
said well if they're not as someone what
are they something you know they're
either you know an individual or an
object
when we
use language in this way it again
reaffirms this this notion that what we
do to animals is a moral issue when we
recognize that there are some ones and
not some things it makes these the
notion of doing something negatively to
them that cutting their throat for
example the idea that's humane obviously
becomes nonsensical but we're constantly
solved this idea of being high welfare
compassionate nice of the animals the
animals are happy to be a part of this
system when deep down i think we all
secretly realize that that's not
necessarily true but it's easier to
believe the lie sometimes than it is to
accept the uncomfortableness of of the
truth and
that scenario
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering 10 off an
annual membership when you use the promo
code rrhealth at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.rich
promo code rrhealth for 10 off an annual
membership all right
let's get back to the show
a lot of that
is is rooted in a lack of transparency
like this inability to make that
connection obviously and i i watched
this debate that you did on television
with the
the dairy farmer who said well we are
transparent and we have people come and
they visit them they visit the farm and
we show them everything and you said do
you show them the part where you slit
the throat yeah and he said something
like
i'd like to think that we're transparent
about that and that and the and the host
of the show to her credit said well it's
a yes or no thing like are you
transparent about that or not right
clearly he's not but he's on television
he's trying to
you know get through this experience
and i don't see a future in which there
will be transparency around that and
that is very much at odds with your
generation and the generation beneath
you that demands a level of transparency
that you know my generation has sort of
been myopic about like that there is
a consciousness that is brought into
consumer choice
that that younger people have where they
expect transparency because they've
acclimated to it because they've grown
up with it and the idea that a
corporation or an industry
would lack that is anathema
yeah and i think there is also
a heightened sense of scrutiny now where
we don't just demand transparency but
i guess we also recognize that these
labels these terms and these adverts
should be scrutinized and we shouldn't
take everything on face value and i
think that is something that is kind of
emerging and new and people are still
kind of maybe
coming to
to grips with that because yeah
fundamentally these industries are not
transparent and the dairy farmer is a
good example of that there is a
perceived transparency there's an
illusion of transparency and that
illusion of transparency can be
perpetuated when we drive and we see
animals grazing you know in the uk for
example it's very common to see animals
grazing lambs cows
it's not an unusual thing to see so that
creates this illusion of firstly
transparency but secondly i guess this
notion of being humane because we think
well how bad can it be because i saw a
dairy cow you know chewing on pasture
earlier
so there is this constant perpetuation
of this illusion of transparency i think
farmers themselves
i think that they can be unconscious in
that as well i don't think that that
dairy farmer for example
knows that he's not being transparent or
thinks that he's not being transparent i
think he thinks he's been very open you
know he does these open farm sundays
where members of the public can come and
see his cows grazing and i think he
thinks that he is genuinely you know
genuinely being this very open nothing
to hide kind of farmer but farmers
themselves
don't go into the slaughterhouses don't
necessarily walk onto the kill floor you
know they drop the animals off drive
away so even they themselves can often
be
i guess oblivious or
maybe willfully ignorant to what happens
in some of these places you know of
course they're aware but even they
themselves maybe don't have the full
picture of transparency that that we
would like them like them to have and
indeed they should have because for a
lot of farmers it can be uncomfortable
i've spoken to many farmers who
will say that dropping animals off at
slaughterhouses is really hard and they
they form connections with these animals
but they kind of say well we have to do
what we have to do they've kind of found
that justification that allows that
difficult
moment in this process of farming to
occur this disconnection this
justification of what we have to do it
and when we justify something by saying
we have to it becomes easy to justify
almost anything terrible if we create
the mentality that's a necessity and i
think farmers do the same they convince
themselves it's a necessity and
therefore that makes dropping off these
cows that they may be misguidedly but
you know maybe themselves individually
really believe they have a connection
with
and i think that's that's hard so i
think there's a lack of transparency
everywhere
and a lack of i guess objectivity and
honesty yeah and of course that lack of
transparency makes it more difficult for
us to understand the emotional
experience of the people that actually
work in these slaughterhouses and have
to operate in the kill room and even so
you know such that even if animal rights
isn't your thing or you have a hard time
like connecting with that and you care
about humans this should be an issue
that you care about because there are a
lot of people that work in these places
who have to endure that sort of psychic
toll day in day out and there's a lot of
literature out there about the long-term
emotional implications of what it's like
to be employed in that capacity it's a
terrible job that none of us want you
know there's a reason why
slaughterhouses are in kind of rural
areas often areas with little job
opportunities and quite simply but no
one wants to work in a slaughterhouse no
one goes to school goes to college
because that's what they want they are
victims of circumstance victims of
environment you know there's incredibly
high turnover rates in slaughterhouses
because people take these jobs out of a
feeling of necessity
and then they can't handle it and then
those that do stay
find ways to handle it that might be
drug and alcohol abuse it might be
violence that perpetuates outside or
permeates outside of the wars the
slaughterhouse you know
there are studies that show that in you
know boomtown counties near large
slaughterhouses the rates of domestic
violence of rape of assault or violent
crimes is exponentially higher and
exponentially increases
and even when they look at the variables
and they look at other
kind of you know maybe working class
jobs such as steel production car
production those rates of violent crime
increases aren't seen it's something
very unique to slaughterhouse work and
it's very easy to understand why that is
now most of us would never want to kill
one animal now imagine a slaughterhouse
where eight hours a day five six days a
week you're killing hundreds thousands
maybe of animals that your job is to
endlessly pull a knife across someone
else's throat
how do you reconcile with that how do
you leave at the end of the day and not
bring that home with you
we expect sly house workers to hang up
the you know blood-soaked aprons and
then just be these completely mentally
competent people at the end of the day
and that's an unfair thing for us to
place on these people and then on top of
that not only are they having the the
pressure of the job but they have the
pressure of being on low incomes you
know being in deprived areas where they
feel completely trapped because there
isn't the availability of you know
working in a different
place and if you don't have that job
then maybe you can't afford to live
maybe you'll be homeless maybe you can't
feed your family and you've got kids to
look after there are all of these extra
pressures and burdens that can lead
people to doing things that they
wouldn't want to do but they feel they
have no choice to
and we're fulfilling and creating that
scenario for our purchases and it's it's
a terrible industry in every conceivable
way even for the humans in that scenario
and that doesn't detract from the fact
that what they're doing is obviously
morally wrong but they are merely
fulfilling the
expectations of the people who are
paying for it you know the blood is on
their hands literally but we're the ones
who are really the blood did you have
the blooded hands because they're the
ones paying for these things to exist in
the first place yeah and i i've talked
about this before but
that you know a version of that scenario
scales up as you go up the the chain of
command at these farms because most of
them
are
[Music]
controlled through debt structures by
these large food companies like tyson
and cargill etc who
basically underwrite the construction of
these massive farms and and create a
system in which it's very difficult to
meet your your your uh
your debt demands
creating a certain type of indentured
servitude with these farmers that they
can never really
scale out of all you know they have to
continue to grow or
or perish essentially and you know
that's not what you know a lot of these
people who farming has been in their
family for generations kind of signed up
for
certainly not i mean there was a huge
boom in these
corporations in the 1980s with
smithfields tyson jbs of course
and they have a complete monopoly of the
market in the uk we have a similar thing
with um like moye park which is a big
chicken producer two sisters so it's a
similar thing across in many countries
not just in the u.s but the u.s has a
uniquely terrible problem with it which
is just
these huge companies they sign contracts
of all these producers it's mainly
poultry producers and pig producers
and those farmers who maybe don't want
to sign these contracts
are faced with a problem which is that
these these companies with the farmers
who are contracted to them are
constantly driving down the cost of
production and through driving down the
cost of production they're producing
cheaper and cheaper food which means
that these kind of more independent
farmers they can't financially operate
in the strains of the market because
it's costing them so much more to
produce the the food they produce
and they're not going to get a good
no one's going to buy it the suppliers
and distributors aren't going to pay the
same amount of money for it to cover the
costs and so a lot of these farmers end
up their hands tied because they have to
sell into these these corporations and
as you say they then have all these
debts and the contracts might stipulate
that they have to update their machinery
every so often have to update the the
methods of farming and so those are more
debts more loans more financial problems
and so they become trapped in the system
where they can't really get out about
incur incurring huge financial problems
which again could make them homeless
could mean they have to leave their
communities not be able to support their
families and so there is this external
pressure which we often don't realize
which is constantly fueling the
continuation of these industries and
many farmers may may wake up one day and
not want to continue farming for
whatever reason that might be maybe an
ethical realization
but then have no choice based on the
financial strains that have been
incurred due to these corporations and
companies and the monopolization they
have on the markets right
the other uh big argument that i want to
talk about is this idea that
if you want to kill
the maximum number of animals the best
way to do that is to go vegan so this is
an argument that was promulgated by
by the great ted nugent on the joe rogan
experience recently
and i've heard this one field it
um before many times and we can kind of
get into that a little bit but
explain
the basis for this argument um and then
let's try to deconstruct it
yeah i mean the basis
for the argument stems from something
which is absolutely true which is that
plant-based farming still results in
animal death um crop production
harvesting results in animals being
killed we can't get around that for the
time being so
it's always important that when we
advocate for veganism myself
i have to make the important
consideration which is that veganism
isn't perfect it's not going to
eliminate all exploitation it's not
going to eliminate all death it's really
a reduction of these things a huge
reduction but a reduction nonetheless so
it comes from an important point to
recognize which is that veganism isn't
perfect and we're not devoid of of you
know of harm by choosing plant-based
foods but the problem is it's kind of
extrapolated up into this really
over-exaggerated thing where you know
vegans are killing all these mice and
these rodents and all these birds and
all these all these other animals at the
same time and well first that's not
strictly true you know when we think
about rodents and we think about birds
it's it's very hard to to catch a mouse
let alone run them over with a combine
harvester they've put like radio
trackers on these animals before um you
know harvested fields and then found
that the populations haven't really been
decimated and they just kind of go leave
the fields if you've got a big combine
harvest to make all this noise noise
vibrations in the ground the animals
don't stick around but insects of course
are killed and will be killed on massive
in crop production and
the idea is i suppose to try and create
a sense of hypocrisy
that vegans are causing death so
therefore there's no point being vegan
but of course
it's about reducing the harm that we
cause and when we look at crop
production for for animals we look at
the mass production of feed in south
america for for animals
even if we just take the basis the
system that we have now significantly
more animals are going to be killed in
the production of animal foods because
not only do you have 80 billion land
animals and 0.8 to 2.3 trillion marine
animals but then you also have all the
animals that code in crop production as
well to feed the animals who we farm
including the farmed fish who were fed
things like soy and stuff as well so
it's a problem that exists for
plant-based farming but the problem that
exists there exists in all of the animal
agriculture space and on top of that you
have all the violence that's committed
to the animals who we eat directly as
well so it's kind of a non-starter in
that sense yeah i mean a couple things
first of all the mice thing the flash
point for that
was
a study or an article
that was misinterpreted because it was
over it was completely focused on a
situation in australia where they have
like this rampant crazy
like
you know mouse epidemic that that
surfaces from time to time that they
have to deal with and so those numbers
were sort of co-opted and extrapolated
to make a broader argument that isn't
necessarily accurate outside of
australia yeah exactly the mouse plague
argument yeah that was uh run with
globally and as you say was used to try
and paint a picture of the global
agricultural scene but yeah the mouse
players are just these
these random events which occur where
there's a huge growth in mice
populations they just overrun fields and
people's homes
um but again the problem is these mice
aren't just targeting fields that are
used to produce crops
for humans they're they're going to
they're going everywhere everywhere and
most of the crops anyway are are growing
food for the animals yeah yeah exactly
they hay straw you know barley types of
grass for for animals and animal product
production
so it's kind of again a non-starter in
the sense of yes of course farmers will
kill these mice when they're trying to
protect the food they're grown directly
for humans but the problem exists for
feed and you know crops we produce for
animals and more of that land has been
used for animals so more mice have been
killed for the animal product production
in the first place anyway yeah
i think it is important to
you know one of the things you said
earlier is
in terms of like how you interact with
people when you have these conversations
is to
acknowledge the merits in your
counterparts argument and i think there
is it is important for vegans in the
vegan community to at least acknowledge
that when they're buying something under
the impression that it's cruelty free to
some extent that's true but nothing that
we do
uh you know lacks a certain kind of
downstream impact i had
um
the biggest little farm couple you know
did you see that documentary
yeah it's nearby here uh and i had i had
them on the podcast and he was
explaining to me
that when he was trying to grow avocados
that
the gophers kept eating the trees and
you know they had a gopher problem or
whatever and in order for these trees to
grow there had to be a certain amount he
he was like listen i don't want to kill
any of these animals but he felt like he
had to in order for this crop to thrive
so his point being obviously when you're
buying your avocado you need to
understand that it's not as simple or as
elementary as you might imagine and i
said yeah you have to acknowledge that
like you have to acknowledge that there
is you know some truth there's a kernel
of truth in this and if we want to be
good advocates for this lifestyle we
have to
acknowledge where things are not as
black and white as perhaps we wish they
were of course i mean nothing is black
and white really and you're absolutely
right we have to acknowledge the
imperfections of what we advocate for as
well and then we can improve those on
the joe rogan podcast it was a different
one with
a guy called chris cresser who james
wilkes went against um when he did the
game changes debates and in this app
this other episode chris cresser has
this study and he uses this to to
provide justification for the argument
that vegans kill animals which is again
a good justif is true but not
necessarily in the scale that they like
to think it is and he used this one i
think he says 7.2 billion animals are
killed in crop production
in the us but the conclusion of the
article is that firstly those numbers
are over exaggerated and take extreme
cons extreme measurements and secondly
that we can work to produce plants in a
way that reduces that and with things
like vertical farming
you know with things like indoor crop
production in these kind of like
underground
dwelling basements as well
there's no animal deaths so of course
right now the system isn't perfect but
the recognition that it's not perfect
then allows us to push ourselves to make
it better sure which is something we can
absolutely do in plant farming as well
yeah but you know just back to this idea
if you're gonna if you want to kill a
lot of animals go vegan and what a
strong man argument that is i mean you
made a video about this where you state
some really impactful
data not the least of which is 75 to 80
of all soy is grown for animal feed only
6 percent is for humans
and 9.5 billion land animals are killed
in the us alone and that's something
like 55 billion if you include
fish
77.3 million acres are used in the u.s
for plants for humans but
127.4 million for animal feed so animal
farming uses 10 times more land 83 of
all global land use is used for animal
farming
so
you know it's crazy when you look at it
through
that lens that the idea that like vegans
are the problem here it doesn't make
sense and also not to mention the
downstream implications of of
of animal farming like let's just take
poultry farms and the waste and the
runoff and how that gets into our water
systems and
you know kills
biodiversity in rivers and creates algal
blooms in in the ocean like are we
counting those deaths and that
damage as well when we're making this
calculation
definitely not and what's even scarier
still is the the numbers that we have
when it comes to animal slaughter are
just the animals that reach slaughter so
it doesn't take into account all the
animals who die on farms which is in the
tens of millions again so
the data that we have or the data that
we often use is not even representing
the full scale of the problem i mean in
the uk we have the worst water bathing
quality in europe and our rivers are all
polluted with chemicals um and some of
that sewage but the biggest cause of
that problem in most of our rivers is
runoff from the agriculture industry
animal agriculture often mostly and even
when it comes to like free-range chicken
farming it's free-range poultry farming
that's polluting one of our biggest
rivers the river y
and that would be a system of farming
that we think is more sustainable and
more ethical but that's actually causing
the problem when it comes to the uh
pollution of this river across um across
england and into wales and such so it is
a huge
fully encapsulating issue that we can
often try and i suppose ignore or demean
by pointing at these straw man arguments
and ted nugent in that clip of joe rogan
goes off on this wonderful spiel about
how you know if you eat the tofu
sandwich it's really terrible for all
these reasons
and he tries to link that into i think
like deforestation the amazon but when
you look at the data in south america
for example this report that 96 of all
the soy produced in south america is
ebay uses animal food for soy like
cooking oil so not in tofu not in soy
milk not in tempeh not in you know the
meat alternatives but animal feed and
then and then cooking oil which is
easily avoided of course um and even ted
nugent he had this really kind of
completely bewildering post
where he shared all these bags of soy
pellets that he had that he feeds to the
the deer that he hunts so he has like
canned hunting so he has deer in this
enclosed space he feeds them soy to
fatten them up and then shoots them to
eat them and then goes on joe rogan and
breaks vegans for eating tofu because
it's made from soy it was this kind of
wonderful moment of uh just pure irony
yeah well it's also a dig at you know
the soy boy idea it's not a mistake that
he chose soy to illustrate that point
right certainly not unfortunately all
right how about this one
ed
we've eaten meat for thousands and
thousands of years this is how humans
developed meat was fundamental to our
brains being the way that they are and
being vegan is just extreme like let's
just be
balanced and prudent
yeah a good argument isn't it i hear a
lot obviously we have eaten meat for
thousands of years
um eating meat allowed us to survive
during times of food scarcity during
cold spells
allowed us to evolve and become the
species that we are today there's no
denying that meat has formed a
cornerstone of human history and indeed
survival in many ways but the point is
it's about where we're at now and in a
current
current modern day society we know we
don't have to eat meat and we can hardly
make the argument that going to
mcdonald's is helping us survive or
helping us evolve you know quite the
opposite in fact so meat consumption now
is destroying our species destroying
destroying the planet causing all sorts
of problems so actually it's no longer
even serving the purpose that it used to
in the past so it's about what happens
now and now we don't need to so it's
irrelevant you know the longevity of an
action doesn't provide justification for
it to continue but the brain evolving
one i think is super interesting um
there's the idea that eating meat
allowed our brains to grow
but actually when you look at something
i suppose a little bit more logical it
makes more sense that it was the
consumption of carbohydrate dense foods
you know tubers potatoes wheat rice that
allowed our brains to to grow because
our brains primary food fuel is glucose
and so when we think about carbohydrate
dense foods these are the foods that are
you know that provide us with the most
glucose so when we started cooking foods
and we started to be able to digest
things like potatoes and wheat and
rice and such it allowed our body to
consume more glucose
and as a consequence of that would
presumably allow me in our brains could
grow bigger and even when they look at
sort of dna um and they look at kind of
fossilized remains of people they
identify enzymes in our mouths that were
there to help us break down starches and
to break down carbohydrates and digest
them and so all the evidence points to
the fact that carbohydrates were not
only an essential part of our diet but
were the reason that we were our brains
grew because we're providing our brains
to the fuel source that it needs to work
at its most optimum
but even if the meat brain
argument were to be true we live in a a
you know in a society now
where
we don't have to be obligate omnivores
we can choose to be herbivores and the
science is pretty clear that you can
thrive on a vegan diet at any age
whether you're pregnant or a small child
we're both living examples of that so
again it goes back to choice yeah
absolutely like you can spend all your
time making those arguments about
whether we're herbivores or omnivores
and looking at our teeth and all of that
but to me like none of that really
matters
it's like here we are living now and you
look at
the
many harmful uh implications of
the way that we you know consume meat
and treat our animals and it just
doesn't it doesn't make sense no and
again yeah you're absolutely right we
can get bogged down with
a forward-facing eyes you know i hear
that a lot or you know well i haven't
heard that one
forward-facing eyes are the signs of a
predator um you know prey have eyes that
can see all around i see predators more
easily so yeah because we have
forward-facing eyes yeah the canine
teeth even though our canine teeth are
really quite rubbish but and the lion
thing it always goes back to the lion
what is that i have no idea it's so
baffling i don't think it's like lions
do this like all these guys walking
around thinking that they're lions it's
bizarre isn't it yeah on the one hand
i'll have conversations and the same
person will tell me that humans are
different to animals because we're more
intelligent and then later in the
conversation they'll go well you know
humans are animals and so are lions so
you know is this like which one is which
one is it exactly
but we do like to compare ourselves to
other animals because again i think
we're trying to constantly appeal to the
idea that it's it's natural and normal
and that it's acceptable for us to do it
because there's a historical precedence
a historical precedent sorry and there's
like this kind of naturalistic precedent
that exists with what other animals do
um but again we can get bogged down all
that but the point remains
now
where we are with the information that
we have with the food that we have
available to us with the knowledge that
we have
we we don't have to and the fact that we
have forward facing eyes doesn't mean
that we're now justified to cause so
much suffering to animals when we could
just eat the plants instead it's a very
good point
in all of these interactions and
conversations that you've had on college
campuses
with young people have you ever met an
argument that you couldn't manage like
what do you think is the strongest
argument
that you've had to field against
veganism
i think it's people's personal health
situations you know sometimes someone
might say something to me about um the
health of a family member and i'm not
necessarily sure how to respond to that
i don't know the the nuances and
intricacies of that individual scenario
when it comes to like the moral issues
when it comes to environmental issues
i've never heard anything that's made me
go oh you know that's you know
something i'm not sure how to respond to
oh that's you know a point i've not
considered but i think you know that you
know people can come up these health
arguments that
they need to do or i tried it and this
is what happened to me yeah and it could
be hard to argue against that because
without knowing the personal situations
what people were eating if they were
supplementing how they were going about
it it's hard to necessarily tell them
that their experience was wrong in that
scenario it's just more of a case of
trying to explain to people that you
know perhaps there was a deficiency or
something you could have done
differently to try and negate those
problems
but i think more broadly than that
something that i really empathize with
is when people talk about family
scenarios you know uh social situations
that's the huge like
it is and i and i think that's one of
the biggest drivers for people
it's just those social environments
whether it's for family whether it's
with friends 100
that this is the right thing to do and
they could have a deep-rooted desire to
do it but their environment and their
surroundings prevent it because the
social ostracization or just just the
the the drain of having to contend with
that is too burdensome for a lot of
people yeah and use that word
ostracization which is a really
important word to use because you know
humans we're social animals we thrive
been in communities been with others and
throughout history our survival has
depended on the participation of others
you know having these communities where
we had these roles where we you know
could integrate together and you know
being outside of that you know not
having that sense of community being
ostracized was catastrophic
so now when we think of veganism it can
be perceived as kind of a form of
self-ostracization and we're removing
ourselves from the safety of the
community the safety of the tribe the
safety of our social groups and so it
can be very daunting because it seems
like we're stepping outside of the
comfort zone and there's a historical
kind of primal fear of doing that
because of of the reliance that we had
on others for survival it's different
now of course but that primal fear i
still think remains and so one of the
most important things about being vegan
is that it normalizes being vegan and it
makes it more accessible for others and
it's kind of like a snowball effect
where the more people who go vegan more
people go vegan simply because more
people are going vegan and it becomes
more normal and yeah accepted and that's
how we can hopefully help people in
those environments but i mean i totally
hear people when they say that because
it is hard to look at a family member or
go into a meal or a social situation
where everyone's doing one thing and you
used to do that and they're expecting
you to continue doing it and then tell
them you're not and then explain the
reasons why you're not and also be aware
that they're going to give you loads of
excuses to why you're wrong and you're
gonna have to feel those excuses while
still trying to enjoy yourself and not
treading anyone's toes and upset anyone
or cause an argument that's
exceptionally daunting so
whilst
it doesn't morally justify what we do i
totally empathize with people in those
environments and i think it's about
creating a sense of normality around
being vegan so that it becomes more
accepted becomes more
mainstream becomes something that people
don't feel as intimidated by
with family i think especially
my family aren't vegan you know that
they're perfectly supportive of what i
do
but they're not
necessarily open-minded to hearing why i
do what i do
and when it comes to family i think
what's particularly challenging is
our parents hopefully try and raise us
to be kind of good people with you know
good morals good values they want us to
integrate into an everyday society and
be good citizens you know hopefully
that's the idea
and so when we turn around to our
parents and we say look i've gone vegan
and in my situation it was look i've
gone vegan because i think what we do to
animals is wrong
i'm kind of criticizing their parenting
i'm saying that they raised me with bad
insurance they raised me with bad values
and for a parent to hear that and in the
case of my parents i know they try to
raise me to be hopefully a good person
to hear that even i'm not you know
explicitly stating that but i'm
implicitly stating it i think it's hard
for a parent to hear and so
there are these dynamics social familial
that are very challenging for us to
acknowledge and address and can be very
intimidating there's these social
structures these
hierarchies that exist within families
and for a child to go to their parents
and say something like that i think can
be daunting and challenging for a parent
to hear and
i understand why that can then make it
difficult for people to want to make
that change yeah i'm very compassionate
about that and we should just
acknowledge the fact that we're having
this conversation in los angeles and you
know you're you hail from london like
these are incredibly
vegan-friendly environments uh
so
um
and most people don't live in places
like that right and i think that speaks
to another
criticism
or argument against veganism which is is
which is this idea that it is elitist
and i think there is a strain of this
movement
that has been
co-opted by a kind of elitist
notion
because
in this burgeoning wellness industry
where high priced items are associated
with you know kind of living your best
life
going to the fancy markets and getting
the latest superfood and all of that
veganism gets kind of wrapped up into
that narrative
and creates
an aspirational lifestyle perhaps but an
inaccessible one for a lot of people
that turn them off to
the greater um
uh the stronger arguments that all route
back to this idea of moral philosophy
i think part of the problem is
you use the word wellness i think that
plant-based diets and veganism have
being have become somewhat
synonymous with this idea of you know
individual wellness and that's why i
always try and emphasize that veganism
is a moral issue where obviously it has
talked about collective wellness oh
collective violence is true but i
suppose when we're talking about kind of
the the pricier and the things that we
can buy
there is this idea that it's kind of
fulfilling that stereotype of maybe an
la person who's you know into those kind
of those pursuits and so i think i try
and acknowledge that veganism is a moral
philosophy
and there are people who
you know eat vegan on a budget and
obviously of course you can be an
expensive vegan you can go to whole
foods or irwin or whatever it may be and
spend you know a lot of money buy meat
substitutes and stuff but that's not
what veganism is you know veganism is
about trying to reduce the harm we cause
and there was a study that just came out
from university of oxford by a professor
called marco springmann and he was
looking at food prices and he said in
the uk at least you know shopping and
buying whole foods so the healthier
plant-based foods reduces your food bill
by
by about a third so you can save money
doing it that way but there is this
connotation of being vegan means eating
beyond burgers and impossible burgers
and you know buying kind of like
superfood powders and stuff and that's
not what it is and it's great if you
want to do that i mean that's all power
to you if that's what you want to do but
it doesn't have to be like that and i
think just trying to help people
understand that veganism doesn't mean
having to shop in these places but can
mean shopping and buying whole foods
legumes whole grains potatoes all these
foods that should make up the majority
of our diet anyway um
is a really important way of making sure
that we can break through that elitist
stereotype
now
it is important to recognize that there
are people who live across the world but
even in the us that don't have the means
to be able to live as comfortably as you
and i do of course no that's that's
fairly obvious and the way the
socio-economic economic structure is set
up there are situations of food
disparity where people don't have the
accessibility that we're used to where
we live
and we have to look at how we can
challenge that and change that
now there is something fundamentally
wrong when buying a beef burger from
mcdonald's is cheaper than buying a pun
of blueberries from a supermarket
there's obviously something wrong
because the production of animal
products costs a lot more than the
production of fruits and vegetables and
whole grains so it shouldn't be that way
but the way that the system is set up
now is that huge amounts of subsidies
are given to
agriculture and animal agriculture
receives the most amount of subsidies to
drive down production costs and make it
cheaper for consumers
at the same time as doing that we have
the system of factory farming which
drives down production costs even
further so we're just constantly finding
ways to bring down the cost of these
foods and then these fast food chains
are opening up in areas where people
don't have the the money to be able to
maybe travel to some supermarkets they
don't have the money to be able to run a
car to pick up groceries and who don't
have supermarkets in their area and the
availability and accessibility that a
lot of us have and so are forced out of
that situation to feed their families on
a budget which can often mean buying
this subsidized cheaply produced meat
dairy and eggs so we have to challenge
that system and the the best way we can
do that is firstly being vegan ourselves
and asking for a different food system
in general and then through doing that
we can start to ask for a change in
subsidy policy you know for example
according to bloomberg last year the
agriculture industry in the us had its
third most profitable year in half a
century
but how does that make sense because it
was during the pandemic yeah restaurants
were shut down there was food you know
problems and the reason was because
there was so much so much money given in
bailouts and subsidies so the animal
farming industry had a very profitable
year because of the government handouts
that were granted to them so if we can
reverse that situation where we can stop
giving subsidies to harmful industries
and instead use these subsidies to drive
down production costs for plant foods to
incentivize you know technological
advancements in in the plant-based food
space we can alter the price of these
products make them more accessible and
available and by being vegan we're
changing the supply and demand scenario
which means that beyond meat and oatly
and all these plant-based companies can
scale up production can reduce costs
over time as well and what we can do is
we can reverse the current paradigm
which is that meat dairy and eggs are
generally cheaper and plant-based
alternatives are generally more
expensive and make not only whole foods
even more inexpensive but also meet
people's demand for the alternatives as
well in a way that is more financially
viable it's a broken system yeah it
really is and i despair
of
the lack of political will to untie this
knot around subsidies that's driving so
many of these problems it's one thing to
speak about the grassroots movement and
shifting demand through
um you know aggregating you know
consumer habits around healthier choices
but
the change also has to come from the top
down in terms of government getting its
head around this you know and and i just
don't when you see this sort of uh
musical chairs that occurs between
uh governing bodies and regulatory
bodies and c-suites of these giant food
companies
it's easy to
like lose my ability to be enthusiastic
about
a potential good future in terms of you
know of of fixing this problem yeah it's
it's daunting and
it may sound slight depressing but even
right now the us the u.s secretary of
agriculture is a guy called tom vilsack
and before he was the current secretary
of agriculture he was the ceo of the
dairy sport council and this is this is
normal operating procedure it's just
revolving door so it is troubling and i
think this is why we as consumers have
to feel more empowered because
our elected officials currently aren't
going to change anything yeah no one's
coming to save us no so i guess there is
yeah there is an empowering it that's
something that can like
provide us with a sense of agency
definitely i mean even think about
climate change and environmental
policies and the green new deal and
these issues that have been spoken about
now when when al gore released an
inconvenient truth they weren't being
spoken about so something's changed and
i think that's because there is now an
appetite within society for these to
become political issues now politicians
just generally follow the trend of what
is
seen as a viable voting concept and
right now changing subsidies from animal
agriculture to plant-based farming isn't
a viable voting concept it's not going
to win votes it'll probably lose votes
so we have to make these issues
something that politicians will stand on
because i'm sure there are politicians
that would be more outspoken who maybe
would agree but they don't want to risk
you know jeopardizing the the votes that
they have and the constituents they
represent so we as consumers have to
make that choice first and then we have
to demand that there is legislative
legislative change that is implemented
as a consequence of us wanting it to
happen because it won't happen if we
keep perpetuating the same systems we
currently do yeah even at cop 26 animal
agriculture wasn't really on the agenda
to be discussed which is just
infuriating it's crazy
even at cop 26 this tom vilsack the
secretary of agriculture here in the u.s
whilst everyone was debating about
reducing methane emissions by 30 by 2030
he was saying to the press that in the
u.s there is no need to reduce the
amount of meats or livestock that have
been produced during cop 26 he said that
and it's just contradicting all of the
science that's coming out even from the
united nations who are telling us we
need to switch to you know plant-based
you know food systems need to transition
in that direction while they're breaking
for lunch and going and eating you know
meat and you know cheeseburgers and
stuff like that so frustrating it's like
it's just like unbelievable right like
you had a you did a podcast with jack
harry's a while back where you guys
discussed this
under this rubric of like can you be uh
can you be an environmentalist if you're
not vegan it was kind of a broader
conversation around
what advocacy means and how we define it
but you know certainly in the wake of
cop26 it's like guys we need to sit down
and talk seriously yeah like what are we
doing it's
it's very frustrating that there has
been such little conversation about this
and i think i mentioned in the book that
there have been some kind of studies
that have shown that
when you look at articles about climate
change and like a few percent of them
even mention animal agriculture let
alone make that a focus
so even within these i suppose what you
consider to be friendly media outlets
places like the new york times or the
guardian or whatever it might be where
we would like to think that they would
be the ones to maybe talk about this
issue but there is still a reluctance to
mention it there's still a reluctance to
tell people about it even with george
monbiot just like going nuts yeah and
the guardian all the time i mean thank
goodness that he exists yeah and it's
that voice in the guardian because if it
wasn't for him
it would feel like we had no one backing
us up in in that media space and
it's very frustrating because people
need that normalization of these ideas
in in the media they consume there's
something called the illusory truth
effect which is that
basically the more you hear something
the more you're likely to believe that
it's true even if it isn't and so if
we're constantly hearing that consuming
meat dairy and eggs is fine it's not a
concern it's moral it's humane we're
going to believe that even if that's not
the case and so we need this
proliferation of content telling people
why that's not true so that we can
challenge this illusory truth effect so
that we can challenge this current
paradigm of the media and people's
perceptions of veganism being something
that's bad when in effect it's
incredibly good in so many ways
well it's a good news bad news thing the
bad news is
mainstream media isn't going to cotton
on to that narrative anytime soon
but there's stuff like this and what you
do that's becoming increasingly
more and more salient and powerful in
terms of shifting uh you know citizen
ideas around these important topics
certainly that's the important thing
about social media isn't it and i think
the important thing about people
realizing that their voice is valuable
and important and that we have the power
to influence our you know immediate
social circles there's a consequence of
that there's a ripple effect you know
where we influence those people they can
influence people in their social circles
and
we as individuals can achieve a lot and
it can be disheartening of course to see
that there are these subsidy policies
and there are these you know
corporations monopolizing the markets
and there is this proliferation of
misinformation that is demoralizing it
can feel like we're up against this
almost inassailable beast of a problem
but ultimately there are shifts
happening and there are cracks forming
in the
you know the otherwise sturdy armor of
these industries and the cracks are
forming and we are starting to to to get
the message heard by people who maybe
wouldn't have heard it otherwise i think
it's just really important to recognize
that change comes from individual action
forming a mass movement a collective
action and we can all be a part of that
so it's about working out what we want
the future to look like you know do we
want this future to be a future which
does seek to reduce suffering that does
seek to create fairer more
equal food systems that means that
people can have options can have
accessibility and availability of
healthy plant-based foods do we want
people to be more empowered to make
individual choices do we want people to
feel empowered to recognize that they
themselves are a part of this huge
planet but also a very small planet
where we have the power to influence
change for the choices that we make and
veganism is a stepping stone i think to
recognizing the broader impact that we
all have collectively but also
individually and it's by no means the
only step we need to need to take but
it's a huge step in the right direction
in fixing tackling addressing
acknowledging
so many different issues that up until
this point we have often turned you know
a blind eye too sadly
ordinarily i would say that's a that
would be a great place to like put a pin
in it because it was like this
super compelling monologue that he was
delivered
but there's a couple more things i want
to talk to you about i want to i want to
um
i want to learn a little bit about surge
which is your non-profit organization
that you founded or co-founded several
years ago that also has a media arm and
now you have a sanctuary like how do you
make all of these things work i mean
we're gonna and i want to talk about the
restaurants too i'm super lucky to have
you know a supportive community around
me of people who you know work in the
sanctuary you know who do the day-to-day
stuff they're looking after these
animals we have over 130 animals now so
you know there's a wonderful group of
people that are doing the day-to-day
work there
um with search so yeah my partner and i
we founded it um five years ago now
and we've just recently been growing the
team um we've got editors animators um
writers and so it's just been a really
wonderful process of us
having this idea of what we want to
achieve and do but then finding other
people that are mission aligned and
incredibly talented people and having
them you know part of this process as
well has been really rewarding yeah the
animators and the filmmakers and the
editors that you have are unbelievable
like the quality of the content that
you're putting out is is so elevated in
comparison to you know everything else
that's out there so i would encourage
you to keep going
um and and part of surge is funded by
unity diner right so you open this
restaurant that's also
ostensibly a non-profit because the
funds are channeled right back into the
into surge that's right so we had this
idea a few years ago
that we wanted to do something that kind
of gave back the community but also
could be used as a method of raising
funds to allow us to do some of the
things that we wanted to do primarily
open the animal sanctuary that we
currently have
so we came up this idea of like a
restaurant
where we would be operating on a
non-profit basis where as you say the
money would go into funding uh search
projects um so we've done like tube ads
you know advertising around london um
and the money's gone towards opening the
the animal sanctuary that we now have in
the kind of
middle of england and so yeah it was
just an idea that we had and it kind of
snowballed very quickly and then we were
like oh my goodness we have this
restaurant none of us know what we're
actually doing yeah so fingers crossed
we can work it out and it's been amazing
um
amazing to meet so many people and it's
given me a newfound awareness of the
importance of food i think that this
thing about veganism
is kind of like a dual process where we
need to give people the reason why but
we also have to give people the how and
without the how the food you know the
the delicious alternatives the recipes
that exist we can talk about the why as
much as we like but people won't make
that change and
having non-vegans come in and and try
plant-based food or at least try some of
these plant-based foods for the first
time the burgers hot dogs whatever it
might be
and you know hearing them you know say
about how they never realized that
plant-based food could taste like this
so they never realized they could you
know have you know fish and chips that's
vegan for example right it's a really
rewarding thing that's the good it's the
no catch company that's right you just
started how many of those do you have
now we have one currently which was just
opened and right
in brighton yeah we um so it's a
completely vegan fish and chip shop and
fish and chips in the uk is a big thing
it's like a huge industry and i was
raised on fish and chips like so many
british people were
and it's a really damaging industry and
and plant-based seafood options are kind
of few and far between
it's still like a very
new niche emerging market
and we have this tow fish product that
we sell at unity diner which people love
it's my favorite thing and we're like
why don't we do something that try and
takes on the fish and chip shop industry
that shows that we don't have to keep
pillaging our oceans and killing you
know trillions of marine animals all the
time that we can do it different way and
so we opened up the shop in brighton
which has been really well received so
far and our plan is to open up more
hopefully around the uk and and kind of
start to make a little bit of a dent in
this uh fish and chip shop
yeah well
you you know you said food is a is a
powerful form of advocacy and i i think
that's a good
um reminder to pivot back to this
conversation that i wanted to have with
you around what constitutes effective
advocacy and
you know we need all different kinds of
advocates we need extinction rebellion
and we need you know peta and we need
people like yourself like whatever
animates you
and whatever feels correct in your
blueprint or your constitution
is is you know is needed in all forms i
think
but i think there are core principles
around things that work and things that
don't work and as somebody who's like
out in the field talking to people all
the time i mean you alluded to it
and we've talked a little bit about it
but
not everybody has your level of skill
and argumentation or your linguistic
abilities so for people who are trying
to figure out how to be effective
advocates in their community whether
it's veganism or environmentalism or
whatever it is that you're you're
passionate about you know how do you
uh you know counsel that person so that
they can be maximally effective in what
they're trying to do yeah it's a really
good question
you are absolutely right that we need so
many different
types of activism types of advocacy
because we're up against this i like to
think of it like a hydra you know like a
multi-headed beast and
we need different types of advocacy to
take off all the different heads of this
hydra and so it's important to not feel
like you have to do activism in a
certain way but just find the voice that
you have and i think apply the skills
that you have and things that you
already enjoy into into your advocacy
because
it's really important to be sustainable
as well and to not feel burn out by
doing things that are grueling and maybe
contradict
our passions in life so if you're an
artist or a filmmaker you're a
songwriter i think combining those
passions with advocacy is a really
important thing but for me i always say
that the primary thing that we should
all do
is take the time to educate ourselves as
vegans to take the time to learn what
people's oppositions are and we'd have
to go too deep i mean i have probably
gone deeper into these arguments than
most people do and most people need to
basically i guess because i'm talking to
so many different people from different
walks of life but i think primarily you
just need to find the main objections
the main reasons that people have and
work out how to to respond to those
and i think that there are definitely
ways of communicating that more
effective than others and so it's about
maybe taking the time to to reflect on
before you were vegan
how would you have responded and i
always think this i would love to sit
down with myself seven years ago eight
years ago and have the conversations i
have now but with myself back then and
to see how i would have reacted um i
don't know how i would have reacted but
what i do know is that
communicating the way i try to now would
have been more effective than
communicating in a more aggressive more
judgmental way so i think trying to put
yourself in that position of the person
you're speaking to and trying to reflect
on what would have worked for you and
can that be translated into what will
work for them is a really important
thing to do but the cornerstone to its
education because education builds
confidence
i
felt deeply and
uncomfortable at the beginning because i
was always worried that someone was
going to say something i didn't know how
to respond to
and i think a lot of my frustration and
my
maybe anger at the beginning when i was
advocating came not from the person i
i'm speaking to but from myself a
frustration that i didn't know what to
say frustration i didn't know how to
respond that i was angry at myself for
letting the animals down because i
didn't have this great rebuttal to this
one argument the person was using so the
more i took the time to research more to
the time to learn and the more practice
i had the easier it got to
be hopefully more level-headed to be
more empathetic to be more
understanding of the personal viewpoint
the person has i'm speaking to because i
felt confident enough of my capabilities
to be able to address what they were
saying that i didn't feel
worried about letting the animals down
or the movement down so i think it is
about education and then practice you
know get used to having these
conversations you could even if you have
a vegan friend just have dummy
conversations with them you know
practice like kind of what we did
earlier you said but ed what about this
and they hopefully gave a good response
i think doing that's a really important
thing to do because it gets you used to
vocalizing your feelings and vocalizing
your beliefs because it's one thing
knowing what you want to say and it's a
different thing actually saying it so i
think just getting you know practicing
having that external vocalization is
also very important it's also the energy
that you bring to the experience i mean
i think empathy and listening are are
super important and
you know just take your videos for
example where you're in these
conversations with people i think
there's sort of an internet sensibility
like oh i'm going to watch this person
own this other person or win this
argument or beat this person
but that's not
what's happening if you're watching what
you're doing closely like you're
engaging this person
you know on their terms at their level
you're listening you're not interrupting
you're trying to understand their
perspective you're acknowledging them
all of these things are critical
um not just in advocacy but in you know
human relations in general right
and i think we're all so quick
to if there's frustrations around that
process of argumentation it's like i'm
trying to win you know and it's like if
you can just let go of that and be
present for that other person
and try to understand where they're
coming from not only will it sharpen
um
your own uh
you know ability to form arguments it
will stress test your ideas and you'll
get better but i think it's it's about
letting go of the outcome of it and just
being available for the experience that
is super important it is i think
fundamentally we all just want to be
heard
we also want someone to listen to us and
take us seriously
and there is this
division
um this kind of binary that
is more prevalent now than probably
it ever has been where i think people
just don't feel heard where they feel
maybe caricatured stereotyped um
and it's really damaging and so when i
have these conversations i guess
the first thing i want to do is just
make sure that the person knows that i'm
not trying to own them you know i'm not
going to put this video up vegan
destroys yeah it's absolutely frustrated
right yeah yeah exactly which is again
why i take those first few minutes the
beginning to build up a bit of rapport
to just let someone feel comfortable
knowing that's not my intentions um and
sometimes i'll say you know don't worry
that's not what we're here to do i just
want a polite conversation because i
think it's really important that people
know that so they can just let their
defenses down and when i upload them
these are long format conversations it's
not like some of the stuff you see on
youtube or it's this chopped up stuff
where someone's made to look silly and
i'm not trying to do that i want people
to be able to express themselves i want
their arguments to be heard and i want
my arguments and response to be heard
and you know the the powerful thing
about making a video is i'm thinking
about the audience as well
and having just two people sit down and
just rationally have a conversation
where they can shake hands at the end
and maybe agree to disagree but still
have that ending means that the viewer
who's watching has been taken along and
they can create their own opinion based
on two opposing arguments how do they
align what do they think you know so
it's i'm not under any false pretense
that the person who sits down with me is
going to leave saying i'm going to be
vegan now it has happened but more often
than not
that doesn't happen
and i try to make the point to people
and i've been seeing it more recently in
the conversations i've just had which
i'll be uploading throughout the near
future i try and say to people at the
end
the reason i'm here isn't to to make you
leave the table saying you're going to
be vegan i'd love for that to be the
case but i understand it's not it's for
you to hopefully leave the table with a
more positive impression of veganism
than you had when you sat down and
that's why i think optics are really
important because
it people don't often remember what
they've heard they remember how that
person made them feel you know we have
arguments with people and we can
sometimes forget what the argument was
about or what the
the the actual points were we can get
bogged down and all that but we remember
how they made us feel and so i want
someone to leave that conversation
having a positive feeling about it
because they might then go and think
about these issues a bit more on their
own because they feel comfortable and
confident doing that because i've made
hopefully veganism something they feel
positively about that it isn't something
that is attacking them that isn't
something that's there to make them feel
bad to call them a murderer or an abuser
but it's instead just an interesting
concept that they actually probably
align with and i think that feeling is
often just as important than the actual
points that i make
and that's why i try and construct the
conversations around that yeah it's not
about not holding people accountable
ever and you know i think that's
important you can hold people
accountable and
question them and in fact the way that
by asking people questions and by having
a more respectful dialogue it allows you
to ask questions that you may not be
able to ask it allows me to say things
to people that i might not felt
comfortable saying because we've built
up an element of trust and i know that
my intentions for saying those things
are not to try and get a clickbait title
and not to try and make them seem silly
that my intentions are because i think
this is an important point and i've
built up enough trust hopefully that
they don't feel attacked and threatened
when i say do you think that's
hypocritical or do you think that's in
disalignment with your morals or do you
think that that's immoral you know these
are a big questions and to try and
to ask someone if they're acting in in
um in an immoral way is a big question
to ask someone but if we can do so in a
way that that is kind of created out of
this respectful dialogue it makes that
question a lot more palatable for
someone to hear and to actually go well
actually yes i think it is immoral what
we do to animals right but the important
distinction being you're asking
questions rather than levying
judgmental statements at the other
person and i think
the more you engender that trust and the
manner in which the question is not only
asked but
but um formed so that you you're not
necessarily coming at them directly like
do you think you're an amoral person but
rather like how does that decision make
you feel when you see this other thing
or something you know there's there's
ways of like getting around it to have
people
stress test their own ideas without you
without coming out somebody from a
judgmental stance and language is such
an important part of that i try to
sometimes i'll use words like you but i
try and use words like we and us you
know how does this impact you know
how do we feel about this or do you
think that it's wrong when we do these
things to animals i mean i know that i'm
not speaking about myself i'm not paying
for some of these things to happen in
the same way but i think using we and us
creates a sense of camaraderie it
creates a sense of joint
responsibility it doesn't make it about
this individual person being bad it's
about we as a collective are engaging in
bad behaviors and we as a collective
have a responsibility to work together
so
language is very important um and
using different language techniques and
using questioning and using different
methods of communication means that we
can talk about really important issues
and really deep philosophical issues and
what could be very divisive issues but
in a way that's actually constructive
and hopefully that that happens
i can't see her and tell you that it
always works perfectly yeah um i can't
see here and tell you that i've not had
people who become
upset angry that maybe don't leave
feeling as positive as i'd like them to
it happens but it's about minimizing how
often that happens and then reflecting
on why it happened you know what did i
say that caused that could have said
something differently and everything is
a
kind of process of trial and error
because we'll never be perfect but what
we can do is i guess just strive to
learn from our mistakes and constantly
better ourselves yeah you seem like
somebody who who knows how to set
healthy boundaries
you know you don't personalize any of
this like you're not letting it
penetrate your
psyche if someone's disagreeing with you
and i think that's part of why you're
you're good at not getting too heated or
reactive in these situations and i feel
like a lot of people
who are
sensitive compassionate people who feel
strongly about whether it's veganism or
some other issue
it's such an emotionally charged thing
and they can't
create that distance or that that that
boundary between their emotional
sensibility and the advocacy so it
spills into it and it actually ends up
kind of
corrupting what they're trying to
achieve
i think what you've said is so important
then um you're right
i really try to detach myself from what
people are justifying if i was to sit
there and think oh this person is saying
that plants feel pain
therefore you know they're allowing you
we didn't talk about the plant the
plants feel pain arguing i mean there's
like 20 more arguments
like eight hours so
i hear a lot i heard the other day
actually it's something very interesting
someone was saying plant consciousness
yeah what about they said what about
thyme leaves and rosemary um now
that's so it seems so arbitrary the line
of conversation is very specific so
specific i think the point was that we
don't need to sp you know to flavor our
foods and so rosemary isn't necessary
exactly so if rosemary can feel then we
should anyway we got off this weird
tangent as you can clearly tell from
from that point so many of the arguments
live so far out on the margins yeah as a
way to justify behaviors because when
you hit the bull's-eye of it it doesn't
make sense so we have to live in these
weird you know artificial
you know examples that aren't really
real life
situations that's true that's true and
uh i have to say to people when they say
about plans for pain i say are you
saying that cutting the stalk of a
broccoli is morally the same as cutting
the throat of a pig or a cow most people
realize that that's not the same some
people will try and take me a little bit
further and they'll go yeah that's the
same and if i was to think about that
and to think about what they're
justifying it would then be a lot easier
as you were saying just before
to have that more emotional response and
so there is this kind of i guess
personal boundary setting there is this
kind of detachment that i have
from thinking too deeply about it um
because it allows me to again distance
the person from the action you know good
people can do bad things so i need to
make sure that i'm
creating that distinction they're
justifying a bad thing but that doesn't
make them a bad person you know these
are all the reasons why they justify it
yes their excuses may seem arbitrary
they are arbitrary yes they may seem
nonsensical because they are but at the
same time i can understand that there is
this
mechanism behind their thought process
there is the social cultural
personal experience that is leading them
to this moment where they now use this
excuse and it's not because they're this
terrible person who relishes in animal
violence it's there's all of this
baggage that has brought us to that
point and having that understanding
helps me just you know keep that
distance from my from the the truth of
what we're talking about to
view it a little bit more intellectually
to view a little bit more as an
abstraction rather than to think about
this is what's happening right now and
this is what they're trying to justify
that definitely helps
right so the book
this is vegan propaganda you did an
amazing job with this book i think this
is going to be a perennial bestseller
you really
[Music]
knocked it out of the park i think it
follows
somewhat the trajectory that we spoke
about today i mean essentially
you talk about your
personal on-ramp into this movement and
you address your general philosophy
around veganism and then you kind of
take a
siri adam us through all of the
different implications of animal
agriculture from
the philosophical and and and
compassionate arguments to the
environmental implications there's a
whole section on pandemics
and health etc
so i highly recommend everybody uh check
it out it's
it's uh it's extremely well crafted and
i'm excited for you thank you richard i
appreciate that very much and how are
you feeling about it i'm nervous yeah i
wanted to write a book that
that people would feel confident giving
to like a non-vegan that kind of like
touched on every argument and hopefully
made a good case for the different
reasons to be vegan um but i also wanted
to have those personal aspects to it
but i'm i'm nervous you know i think
because it's
it is just just me you know it's just my
thoughts my my feelings it's such a
personal thing to write because you of
course will know yourself and you know
making the search videos is
collaboration having a restaurant
collaboration it's all collaboration and
of course there's so many people have
helped the book you know from
the publishing house and such but having
that real personal thing that's gonna be
out there for people to buy and review
and judge and i guess also importantly
formulate their opinion about veganism
over it's uh it's quite quite
nerve-wracking yeah i'm trying to
remember if there has been
a book about veganism that has
approached it in this kind of
comprehensive way in in recent memory i
mean it really is and i when i gave you
a blurb i made this comparison to peter
singer i don't know how you feel about
that but i do think there are parallels
like you are
your generation's version of that like
you have decided to shoulder this
mantle this responsibility and this book
is a is a product of everything that
you've been talking about in your videos
for some time and it's done
in a way where i think
obviously it's going to appeal to people
who are vegan but it really is written
with this sensibility that it's not
necessarily intended for those people
it's really intended
for you know the vegan person who gives
it to their friend or says maybe you
should check this out and it's very
welcoming in that kind of tone and tenor
oh good that's exactly what i wanted i
wanted a book that was a book that
vegans could read and they would
probably learn things maybe they didn't
already know about so it was a good tool
for them to become better advocates but
i always wanted it to be a book that was
for a non-vegan to read that was for
that reluctant family member that
skeptical friend or even just the
curious person in the bookshop and
the the point of the title i suppose is
to be grabbing to kind of be a little
bit tongue-in-cheek so people kind of
raise an eyebrow you know the cover
itself is quite bright it's a bit
different it has this kind of like
kind of soviet soviet era right yeah
it's all propaganda oh probably the
whole thing yeah exactly toss it in the
garbage just really wanted to play on
that exactly it's not worth the paper
it's printed on but we really wanted to
play with the idea of it being this kind
of propaganda piece so that people could
read it and go
oh this is what these industries are
calling propaganda
oh okay now i understand why they call
it propaganda and you know everything's
extensively
referenced there are citations and i
just wanted to kind of draw people's
awareness to the fact that
when farmers are accusing or when the
industries are accusing vegans of
spreading propaganda they're not
attacking vegans they're attacking the
scientific literature they're attacking
our moral compasses they're attacking
something more objective than this
vegan bias that can sometimes
be perceived as existing and it's really
an attack on
so much more than just vegans and i
think i want people to read the book and
hopefully reach the end and go
okay i understand that now i understand
why they call it propaganda and
potentially there is another side to
this story and
the way the book is structured having
the first section about ethics and
morals was important to me because
that's
why i came into this and is the most
important thing for me but then having
that middle section that talks about the
environment pandemics chronic health to
show the true enormity of it but then
the final section is about the mechanism
behind it because as we've spoken about
quite extensively today
it's good it's not just about having the
understanding of why it's bad it's about
having the empowerment to understand why
we act in the way that we do and how we
can get through that i think the first
thing we have to acknowledge is the
barriers that are in place how our
behaviors have been influenced why
they've been influenced and through that
we can then put into practice changing
our behaviors to align with all the
reasons why we should and that's why
that's why i stretched it in that way to
that hopefully a sense of empowerment
about what we can achieve well it
definitely comes across and you should
be very proud thank you rich
ed you're a powerful voice and i have so
much respect for the work that you do
um if i can ever be of service to you i
just you know i think what you're doing
is really important and it's been cool
to spend a couple hours with you so
thanks for doing it i appreciate thanks
for having me it's great to connect and
yet
to pick your mind and to have this
conversation has been really wonderful
and i appreciate your support with the
book as well absolutely man so everybody
go pick up this is vegan propaganda ed
is easy to find on the internet he's at
earthling ed pretty much everywhere but
start on his youtube page and go down
the rabbit hole of his many how many
videos you have now i mean you got tons
of stuff quite a lot and
we try to create a variety of content as
well but i've got by the time this
podcast goes up i'll probably have quite
a lot more as
often do you upload not as often as i
should um but because i'm expanding the
team um getting an editor who's helping
me out and stuff
um they'll be more consistent and the
past few weeks i've got so many debates
that we're just starting to work our way
through so uh yeah there should be a
good healthy number of debates on my
channel by the time this goes up good
deal um all right man we'll come back
and talk to me again sometime i'd like
to thanks everybody peace
do
[Music]
you